s oh absolutely give me just one
moment uh representative uh chairman
yes so I'm getting a new gas stove
delivered today and they're just pulling
up so I have to step away for a minute
to let them in the house uh but I I am
here and you'll you'll see me come and
come and go okay thank you
representative
Ville and you're all set to start
chairman PE all right good morning
environment ad committee for those in
person and those online we welcome you
this
morning I'm going to read this a quick
script Sor getting a little feedback
here guess it's my
unit can
everybody representative Kennedy can you
check yours please
how about
now representative stapon you might need
to turn your volume all the way down
yeah perfect that sounds much better
thank you all right are we good
now yes all right good morning everyone
uh I'm going to read this quick
script as chair of the environment and
agricultural committee I find that due
to the state of emergency declared by
the governor as a result of the covid-19
pandemic and in accordance with house
rule 67 in the governor's emergency
order number 12 pursuant to executive
order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a public hearing
on bills referred to the committee an
executive session may follow please note
that there is no excuse me there is no
physical location for members of the
public to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
Zoom platform or by
telepone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website the notice for this meeting
complies with house rules and RSA 91 a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call
27136 or email
HCS
l.st new hampshire.
Us in the event the public is unable to
access this meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled Christina Dyer
is the staff assisting us please note
that all votes that are taken during
this meeting shall be done by roll call
vote and we'll start the meeting by
taking a roll call me roll call
attendance when each member states their
presence please also State whether there
is anyone in the room with you during
this meeting which is required under the
right to no law I'll ask the clerk to
call the
role thank you Mr chair
um represent Aaron pres thank represent
pres represent
fgo
pres uh representative Davis
here St here in the committee room
representa here and in the committee
room representative Kennedy here
in representative
Mason represent
Sor represent sor
representative
Bixby here in my uh study in my house
and I'm
alone um good morning I'm I'm here and
I'm at my house and I'm all alone in
ashaa B I'm here in the committee room
represent Duty H yes I'm here in my
office alone my husband is in the other
part of the
house repres
Mar I am here and I'm um alone in this
part of my house um my husband is
somewhere else in the house and my
children will be returning later in the
dayski here in Kean in my office
alone
kapan here uh in my study in hener all
on my own repres
Highland also home uh alone in my home
office my husband is around but he won't
be here represent Perez um here in my
off in my office in Milford
along I am here in the committee room
with with all the wonderful members of
the
ENA Mr chair I'd like to ask represent
Kennedy if she sees represent Mason or
represent s on the phone
not I do know repres cative Mason will
be a few minutes late he had an early
appointment thank you very much so we
have thank you to the
clerk all right we are 9:07 so we're
going to go right into our first hearing
House Bill
585 allowing the prepayment of dog
licensing fees for the duration of AR
rabies vaccination and reducing fines
related their to and I will recognize uh
representative Leon to speak to the Bill
thank you Mr chair and thank you
honorable members of the House
environment and agriculture committee I
am representative Erica Leon
representing Rockingham district 6 Dair
and I am the prime sponsor of this film
for years I've wondered why dog licenses
are only offered for one year when the
most common rabes vaccine lasts three
years I spoke with my town clerk about
this issue and he agreed that allowing
the license to last as long is the
current vaccination would decrease his
burden in chasing down dog owners with
laps licenses while making life easier
for residents HB 585 allows a dog owner
to choose to register their dog for
either one year as provided for
currently or for a period of three years
the intent was to allow the license to
last as long as the current baby's
vaccination and the bill is silent on
the details of implementation on the
part of towns due to my conversations
with town clerk Dan Healey and his
discussions with other Town clerks
implementation of the current law is not
standard across towns so detailing how
towns would deal with this seemed overly
burdensome one of the big questions from
town clerks is how they would provide
for refunds this bill makes no
Provisions for refunds and leaves the
current one-year license in place as an
option for people with elderly
dogs might otherwise seek a refund the
other major part of this bill is a
reduction in fines associated with laps
dog licenses the current fines are
significant when compared to current dog
license fees a spade or neutered dog
cost $7.50 each year to to register and
the current forfeiture fee which is
assessed 20 days after fines begin start
at $25 which is over three times the
annual licensing fee for seniors who we
respect with a $3 annual dog licensing
fee this for forfeiture f is over eight
times their annual licensing fee the
reduction in fee to $10 still provides
teeth but it reduces the bite for dog
owners who may be facing Financial
hardships right now the requirement to
pay the dog license between January 1
and May 1st adds a third visit to town
hall to my annual schedule I pay it
can't pay it in December when I pay my
car in one of our property tax bills and
if I wait to pay it in July when I paid
for my husband's car registration and
our other property tax bill then it's
late and I have the $25 fine I know that
it's not a huge burden but our town
clerk sees lots and lots of frustrated
dog owners who were in and it would make
life easier for him and there would be a
lot fewer grumpy people in town hall and
I say that would be a win for
everybody so this dog would keep this
bill would keep dogs registered with
current vaccinations which is the
intention of dog licensing I realized
that I overlooked a few points when I
drafted this bill with the Hope help of
os I'm happy to put in an amendment to
go to finance that addresses the issues
like one of the sources of fees um if
that would help you and I'm happy to
take questions that you do have I do
have a exact session on hb20 so
hopefully I can be pry prompt with the
answers thank you thank you
representative so I uh presented this
bill language to My Town Clerk and just
put it through to see some questions
that she had and she gave me a few and I
certainly won't dominate a lot of the
time but there was a couple of prominent
ones that you might like to speak to so
H what about a a puppy with only a
one-year rabies booster how how would
that be addressed um a puppy with only
one-year radies booster should be
registered with only the one-ear vaccin
only the one-year license because the
intent was that the duration would
correspond with the r
vaccination and one other question that
I thought was notable is uh what if the
person has multiple dogs with multiples
rabies expiration dates how would that
be handled um with that I know that that
doesn't really help their burden um so
maybe a one-year license for them still
makes sense if they're having to come in
if the dogs aren't on a consistent
schedule
thank you any other questions from the
committee representative Balden uh thank
you Mr chair and thank you to the
representative for taking my question um
you might have mentioned this in your
testimony but I might have missed it
what is what would be the cost for
getting that
three-year um bulk license basically uh
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for your question the
cost should be three times the annual
license because you were simply
prepaying for those additional three
years as opposed to getting any sort of
discount most of those fees do go to
provide a lot of different services and
I think that it would be inappropriate
to Short change those Departments of the
revenue that they count on from those
licenses okay follow followup um thank
you for taking my followup what I'm do
you know what the number would be I I'm
not 100% clear on what the existing
number is so I don't know what to
multiply by three to get that number oh
I'm sorry about that the for a spater
neuter dog and I believe a puppy as well
um who's below the age Bay a Neu in it's
$7.50 a year so that would be 2250 for a
three-year license for um intact dogs
it's $10 so that would be $30 for the
license and for senior citizens there
have a $3 license fee that would be $9
okay and just one more one more follow
all right um thanks my final followup um
I I assume um that the the
fine being lowered to $10 that that
would be that would be $10 for failing
to register that for that three-year
license um if if registering or getting
the license would cost $22 but the
Fine's only $10 doesn't that give a
financial incentive to not actually get
the dog
registered um thank you for your
question representative if you have
somebody who's not looking to register
their dog there's already people who
don't register their their dogs right
now keeping that intact respect those
those residents who are on a more fixed
income who may be the ones more likely
to register each year and then possibly
r a follow of those fines if this is
something where our town clerk does not
rely on those fines it's more of a
hassle for him to have to chase these
people down and for most people that
doesn't make a significant difference
between t $10 and $25 but for the less
financially secure residents of our
state it is a big difference and I think
that we should respect them in that
decision thank you thank you thank you
I'm GNA take uh representative Duty
uh thank you for taking uh my question
uh representative Leon I have a couple
of questions um the way I read this bill
initially uh is that the fees to the
neutering program decrease startup costs
increase tag inventory cost
increase fees decrease so the money
going uh to the state lab and other
programs to support um uh animal
Licensing in the state looks like it's
going to be decreased uh secondly I
thought t uh several Town clerks also
depended uh on their income you know
from uh dog licensing fees so I was
wondering why that was SE to be such a
large part of the
bill thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for the question as I was
researching this and working with OS it
was completely overlooked that the
department vet AR diagnostic laboratory
gets money from the licenses this is one
of the areas that I would be glad to
prepare an amendment for the committee
if that would be helpful I know with our
time frame that may be better dealt with
in finance if you choose to move this
bill forward um but I would like to do
whatever I can to remedy that
situation as far as the as the
costs I right now the only thing that
would be reduced would be the fines for
people who don't pay and now there is a
provision for uh a cost in order to
track these track that these people down
I I question the business or the model
of relying on fines from residents who
do not comply um that are punitive fines
as a way of funding an apartment this is
it just incentivizes people to break the
law and to not respect the laws and I
think I I'm concerned if that is an
important budget item in any town
and um that that's just that's just sort
of a philosophical issue for me you
shouldn't be relying on fines um did I
get both all of your questions
representative yes uh thank you I
appreciate that thank you all right
thank you uh representative hola thank
you chair and thank you representative
for um taking my questions in and
introducing this actually I think it's
very practical the one question I did
have was sort of on the reverse of the
previous question are there any costs
that are baked in right now to that $7
50 that represents just the the time
that the clerk has to handle it and if
we if we don't require the clerk then to
be handling these every three years even
if it's a dollar wouldn't that sort of
wouldn't that sort of um sort of paying
the clerk for something that you're not
doing every year now so is there any
thought to that or do you have any
figures on what that dollar amount is
that is just sort of the clerk handling
fee uh thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative um as I had added these
up before I thought that there were
several dollars going to the clerks but
I had missed $2 that goes to the
veterinary lab so the amount that they
get is quite small and actually would
subsidize any senior dog senior dog
owners because they they pay $3 which is
less than the fees that go to other
departments okay there may be a
difference in handling costs but when I
spoke with my town clerk who is involved
in the town clerks Association some
towns may not want to get three
different license tags and it may be
easier for them to just annually send
those out when they come around check a
spreadsheet that says that they're
already paid up for the three years and
because if they do handle it on a more
manual basis with the same one-ear tabs
that wouldn't reduce the burden at all
for the clerks so I see that because
we're silent on implementation it makes
sense to keep those levels intact thank
you thanks thank
you all right uh I will recognize
representative Highland
thank you Mr chairman for taking my
question um I was just going to go back
to the hassle um that you had mentioned
about um you know coming in to do all
these different payments and having to
think about the licensing um at a
different time um in our town here in
Francis town all of this can be done
online I was curious if that is the same
for your town and if it's the same
across the board and if that should be
considered um that all these at least
the renewal can be done online I'm not
sure about the original the initial
licensing I'm just curious about that
thank you thank you Mr chair and thank
you representative we are able to pay
this online but when we do that there's
a $1.75 credit card fee to do that
online and for $7.50 registration as an
economist I just I just can't click that
box that enables the $175 I know that I
also could write a check and drop that
in the mail with the 50 Cent um stamp
but when it comes down to it this would
reduce the number of grumpy people in
town just because they're able to get in
there it would just make everybody's
life easier and as we've seen with um
with social distancing and all of this
with covid it's kind of nice to be able
to reduce the foot traffic because that
that does improve the quality of service
and just the the environment at the Our
Town Halls so thank you for your
question all right I will recognize
representative Bixby
yes thank you for thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question um do
you uh happen to have any idea how
frequently um fines are issued in order
to enforce uh uh the licensing
Provisions um thank you Mr chair and
thank you representative right now in
Dair I believe they have close to a 100
that they issue but a lot of times they
wave them if people come back right away
because it makes for Less contention at
Town Hall so there are sending out these
checks people come bustling in and say
I'm so sorry I forgot to pay for my dog
license and they're good people and they
often wave those fines but it just
becomes more of an issue for people
there's others that obviously come in
with a demanding attitude and they're
probably a lot less likely to have those
fines waved but it's I guess the
question is are you looking to see
whether or not this is actually a
problem or if it would hurt the income
for the
towns right I was just getting wanted to
get a sense of the the scale of the
problem thank you I I don't know the
exact scale but I do know that they send
out a significant number of D okay thank
you all right uh I'll recognize
representative
Aaron thank you so
[Music]
much question is I know in my town um
each year when we our dog she gets a
different colored
T so you know you know how they would be
able to manage have a
threee you know it seems like it would
be so complicated
Forks to
manage different
scenarios uh thank you Mr Shar and thank
you representative for your question I
also wondered how best to implement the
tags because they do change here year
and this is something that I took to my
town clerk Dan Healey and he took to the
cap Town clerks Association um they were
split between Town clerks would rather
just annually send out that same tag
while uh my clerk would actually with
the size of dairy would go ahead and
order those three years just like they
do for license plate stickers so that
when it does come in they would have
that color and that correct tag that
goes for the entire duration of the
licensing uh town to Town the desired
implementation differed a lot which is
why we didn't put any mechanism into
this and it leaves it leaves that
implementation up to the
CL I additionally um I don't see any
mechanism here for any kind of refunds
or you know say you get a threeyear
license for your uhy old dog and
unfortunately within a year or two dog
dies so you're left with paying for
license for extra year two you
need or even if the animal is
transferred to somebody else it's a
younger
animal how would that work there be any
position for refunds uh thank you for
your question that's another one that I
talked to with my clerk and he spoke to
the clerks
Association having a mechanism in place
for a refund would have made this very
very burdensome for the clerks and that
is one of the reasons to leave it
optional right now my dog is five years
older than myself
13 they have the same birthday so I as
we've been wanting to do this we tried
to have this in as constituent Bill
years and years and years ago and now I
understand why it didn't go in it's more
complex than I realized but uh it's
something where you if they have the
option you may you would value the
convenience of only having to Reg
register every three years over the
potential of not getting a refund so
this is one of the many reasons to leave
the one-year license intact especially
for our less financially secure
residents those with older dogs those
that may or may not be May uh see a
shorter duration of ownership and it
seemed like the best compromise without
creating a need for an escrow fund or
anything else it would just be far too
much for such a a low transaction cost
all right representative Bixby did you
have another
question no sorry I just forgot to take
my hand down all right we'll forgive you
this
time U actually that transitions into
another question that my town clerk had
so I guess I'll jump in her question was
uh if if they are licensed for three
years and someone has a non non-altered
dog and they uh get it altered in that
three years would they be looking for a
refund so I guess you're sort of answer
is probably going to be similar to what
you just gave about the refund uh thank
you Mr chair yes uh the answer would be
that there AR refunds so if you're
looking for your situation to change
within those three years it makes more
sense to get the onee license all right
thank you any other questions for the
representative before I let her go
representative comp yes thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question um just in listening to all the
questions being asked um would this make
it more complicated for some of the Town
clerks having a oneyear license and a
threeyear license because it seems like
they would have you know they have to
keep track of different states where
right now it's every dog is licensed
every year on April 1 um is technically
the time frame now you're it's it's a
moving Target would that make it more
complicated for them uh thank you Mr
chair thank you for your question
representative this this was another
concern that I had I know that in Dairy
they look they use more of a spreadsheet
there was some discussion about software
but I that I wasn't aware that there was
any software in order to manage this
because this is done on a list based uh
system at least in deri and I would
assume in smaller towns they figured
that they would just add a couple
columns to it so that just as when
somebody comes in January 1 they're
marked off is paid and they otherwise
would have them as unpaid knowing who to
who to track down they would have that
information and just add a couple
columns to their spreadsheet to keep it
on an Ono
basis so there's one other question um I
thought that the uh Department of a was
going to jump in and testify but I don't
have them on my list so I'm going to
actually ask it it was raised by Dr
Crawford about the fees going into the
spay and neutering fund uh have you
given any thought to how that would
impact the the state's Revenue because
they would all of a sudden be getting
three years worth of Revenue in one year
and perhaps not in the other years did
you have that conversation with the
department at all um thank you Mr chair
that is a wonderful question because
these are would be running concurrently
with the three years rabies vaccination
I don't have any reason to expect that
there's an unequal distribution of these
vaccinations so if in year one you have
uh just the dogs who are who have been
newly vaccinated would be eligible for
that three-year license so there would
be a small ballist at that point then at
year two the dogs who in that second
year came into their three-year baby
cycle would then be eligible for that
threeyear renewal and the same thing on
the third year so there'd be some Bas up
front but because you would be renewing
these dogs on that threeyear basis and
then the individual one-year renewals it
should actually just give a little bit
more money up front but continue with
those fees over on overall thank you I
do not see oh representative Aon one
more sorry not going in on
me with that in and being on commit in
my
town you know certainly that is a budget
item of income for the town is you know
thec
and you think that that would also come
into play for being a very
volatile item to manage for a town
budget I mean I know it's not a huge
number still something the town clerks
ands have to
on um thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for that insightful
question that is another one of these
areas where as you look to how much is
going out immediately to these different
programs the amount that stays on the
town is relatively small but it could be
a significant impact um I think that
that probably would require more study
and I apolog oliz that I didn't dig
better into this I had two bills that I
put in this year one was for improving
checklist maintenance and this bill is
actually far more complex than working
on our
elections because there's so many moving
pieces if there's still lingering
questions and this is something that you
want to retain and would like me to work
on over the interim I'd be happy to do
that because it is a complex topic that
I think would benefit our citizens and I
would like to see this happen and even
if it doesn't happen this year I would
like to see this as as an option well
thank you we'll certainly take that into
consideration not looking at the time I
know you have another commitment so U I
don't see any more hands and I I
appreciate you coming in and introducing
the bill and it's been a great testimony
thank you thank you very much and I I
appreciate thank
you could you email us your testimony
yes I will do that as soon as I go back
to my computer my iPad wasn't
cooperating thank
you I'm going to ask the clerk to
recognize that uh representative Mason
has now joined
us all right uh next we have Nancy
Holmes representing herself as a member
of the public Nancy are you able to
unmute and join us um yeah I think I'm
unmuted am I you are good go ahead Nancy
okay good to go okay um I I was
listening pretty carefully but I had a
cat inter eruption one of those problems
with uh working at home and I missed
where um anything was said about the
spay neuter fund getting its money the
bill as written does not allow for any
money going into the spay neuter fund
and I see that as a big issue um that
fund is uh put New Hampshire in a very
good place in terms of animal
overpopulation issues and our shelter
problems um and you know like I said
maybe I just just missed that um the
other thing that I I had a concern about
aside from the written testimony I sent
in was group licenses now for years I
bought a group license because I had a
number of dogs and it was a it was a
good savings for me to do that um how
would a three-year group license work if
it could um you know the um other people
touched on some of the other concerns I
had in terms of you know what if you
transfer a dog what if the dog passes
away um H but they didn't get down into
the the gritty details of it which is
okay if you do a refund then does the
state lab have to give money back does
the Spain neuter fund have to give money
back or is it only the town portion you
would get back um I I do see this as as
being I think more complex than was
thought I also can see how um the intent
was excellent in terms of making dog
licensing more convenient but let's say
you have three dogs and everybody's on a
different vaccination schedule for
licensing you're still going to be back
at Town Hall every year just to keep
track of who needs what because you
can't buy uh you wouldn't be buying a
three-year license for all three dogs at
the same time unless of course you were
buying a group license which I think is
for five or more dogs so those are some
of the questions I had and I I really
hope that um maybe some more thought can
be put into this bill because I think it
could work but not sure the consequences
are completely understood and the other
thing I have to say is about those
lovely rabies tags I have yet to have a
single rabies tag last more than four
months on a
dog I don't know what they do with them
um I found one stuffed down the heat
vent once um I found other people's
rabies tags along the dog walking trail
but um I I can't imagine that a a
three-year tag would ever be available
on the dog after the first a little bit
so um you know th those are my concerns
like I said I understand the intent was
nice but um I'm not sure the uh
practicality of it
is you'll be happy to answer any
questions if somebody had any questions
about my written verbal testimony all
right thank you any questions for
Nancy do you see any
hands all right I think we're gonna let
you off easy Nancy thank you great
thanks
all right uh is there anyone else that
would like to testify on this
bill all right then I'm going to close
this bill for public testimony and
actually I think I'm going to go right
in and then think we're going to exec it
right now um and I'm going to look to uh
representative Arnold to make a motion
Mr chair I move
Bill all right representative Arnold has
moved to retain do we have a
second uh I will second that um I will
second that representative Bixby thank
you so we have a representative Hood
moves to retain and representative Bixby
has moved to Second do we have any
discussion from the committee um yes Mr
chair I just uh I think that uh what we
um heard in the in testimony was that uh
it seems like it's a generally good idea
but um there are a lot of details that
still need to be worked out and um
working those out within our deadlines
and within our um with a limited scope
for doing extra meetings at this point
uh isn't makes it diff I don't think we
could get it out by uh crossover so um I
I think that it would make sense to
study it uh in the fall and then um um
bring back an amendment
version thank you representative I I
also would agree that while I certainly
appreciate and uh I like the concept I I
do believe there's a lot of details
especially related to the revenue to the
department and to the questions that the
uh Town clerks have raised that deserve
some uh time that we don't have to give
right now so I I would agree is there
any further comments or questions disc
session from the
committee all right seeing none I'm
going to ask the clerk to call the role
so the the clerk is looking for a motion
to
retain Mr chair yes uh could I just
request that uh people have their
cameras on for this yes they they need
to sorry thank you
representative I'll ask everyone to turn
your cameras on
all right looks like we're
good go
[Music]
ahead
yes yeses vervo
yes representative Davis yes
representative steton yes
represent yes representative Kennedy yes
representative Mason yes
represent
sorn represent viby yes represent
SAS yes
sorry represent D yes represent Murray
yes represent vinty yes
yeses kapan
yes represent
Highland
yes
yes chair yes U PL yes I didn't get to
vote and my name was not called I'm
usually after to represent I'm sorry
represent I would like to vote Yes
soriz okay motion passes and what was
the
18 to
zero all right thank you Christina are
you
on yes I am can you reach out to
representative sanbor she has just
messaged me that she is having
difficulty finding the link so would you
uh reach out to her and provide that for
her absolutely thank
you all right looks like we have time to
keep going with uh we'll exact uh House
Bill
249 all right I'm going to look to
representative Aaron for a motion
I
to did you have an amendment you wanted
to
[Music]
offer to9
all right do we have a second
representative Aon we're having a hard
time hearing you online are you able to
speak into the
microphone you hear me now yes much
better thank you sorry about
that okay so this is
am29 do we have a second for that yes
representative dsy seconds that motion
all right thank and I'll recognize
representative Aon to speak to her
motion so this
bill current statutes RSA 437 col one to
allow for animal shelters to the C and
these facilities it also requ
Dogs Out
Shel representative if I can interrupt
the you need to speak to the amendment
first oh I'm sorry that's okay okay um
so particular
Amendment says that all
cats three months of age or older shall
be vaccinated against radies in
accordance with
RS
transfer vacination is not available it
also to the
bill section that says if listed owners
or agents cannot be located or refuse to
re possession
theal and I'll further add that the
first section under Section B was uh
just to clarify that the uh you know
younger pets under three months of age
would uh would be following the current
statute that's
43600 this was a point that was raised
by representative Bixby during the
hearing and uh it seemed like a good
idea so I think this amendment will
clarify
that any further discussion on the
amendment all right seeing none I'm
going to ask the clerk to call or will
call vote on amendment number
202-349-7000
repres
yeses yes represent Vero
yes Davis yes steton
Yesa yes representative Kennedy yes
represent Mason yes represent
s looks like she's on
yet represent Bixby yes represent SAS
yes representative Balden yes
representative
Dy represent
dy I believe you're
muted D just give her a sec
she all right representative duty is
giving me a thumbs up and she seems to
be having some difficult
unmuting something else popped up again
yes I vote Yes sorry all right thank you
muray yes represent viny yes represent
Kaplan yes repres
Highland yes represent
Perez yes Mr chair yes motion passes
adoption all right so now we will
[Music]
to representative Aaron for a motion to
move as
amended yes I move
H49 the amendment
TPA and that is amendment number 202
1-349 do we have a second yes
representative Duty second
spot thank you so we have a motion a
second representative Aon would you
recognized to speak to your motion thank
you so again um the entirety of this
bill excuse me the entirety of this bill
um updates a statute RSA
4371 to allow for animal shelters to
house and Lease facilities it also
requires dos cats and carrots
transferred out of shelters to have
needs of identification and to be
vaccinated against rabies it also
stipulates that when dogs cats to
shelter which have been abandoned for
unpl as find in RSA
4378 that within 72 hours every means of
contacting the previous owner or owners
is made in order for the animal to Beed
and lastly the bill requires that any
dog cat or feret received from outside
of the state of New campshire required
to have an official health certificate
and meet quarantine requirements before
being transferred to any
person thank you representative and this
is a bill that um worked the
stakeholders with from the shelters and
the various breeders groups to make sure
that we had language that worked very
well so I appreciate all that had input
is there any further discussion on the
bill seeing done I will ask the clerk to
call the role for an otpa on House Bill
249 with Amendment
49h yes
represent yes represent Vero yes
represent Davis yes ston yes MOA
yes Kennedy yes
Mason
yes
s uh she is here um she just needs to
unmute and turn on her camera
represent viby
yes represent
sopus
yes yes represent Dy yes represent
Murray yes represent vinsky yes
represent
Kaplan yes represent
Highland yes repres Perez yes Mr chair
before I vote I'll ask representative s
to turn on her camera and
unmute it looks like she may be having
some technical
difficulties we'll give it just another
second because I do see she's trying
can you hear me
now s are you able to turn your camera
on oh I'm
[Music]
trying well I don't
see how to do that
[Music]
representative sanbor would you like me
to give you a call to see if we can work
this out if you would please
okay I'm going to uh
I'm going to uh not allow you to vote on
this because you're not able to get your
camera on but we'll certainly get you in
on the next one so
uh the chair votes
yes all right so we have vot of 180 for
an otpa is there any objection to
putting this on the consent
calendar see none
Dix did you have a question yes uh I
just uh realized we didn't um uh bring
up the idea of putting oh never mind
it's a retain motion it doesn't go into
the calendar my bad that's okay no
question I appreciate you keeping an eye
on
me I think I'm gonna take a 10minute
recess here to give representative
sandborn an opportunity to get her Tech
issues worked out before we move on to
uh doing any exact session we have
another hearing in about 10 minutes so
we'll uh we'll be in recess until 10:00
a.m. where we will be hearing House Bill
e
e e
for
for for
sure for
St
e
e e
representative sandbo can you hear
me okay on both the phone and the
all right representative Sor can you
hear
me okay can you hear me now I can and
can you hear me I can Perfect all right
we're all set to go fantastic okay thank
you
Christine so welcome
sure yeah it just helps
right um chairman Pearl I just wanted to
say we've got representative sanbor um
up and running and if she just does the
91a um where she is and where she's at
we should be able uh to move forward all
right thank you I'm here I'm
here all right being 10 o'clock I'm
going to ask the clerk to recognize
representative sanbor and call her into
the
role representative sbor could
you where you are uh I am in my home in
my kitchen by
myself thank you very
much all right I'm now going to uh open
the hearing for House Bill 387 an act
relative to rabies vaccinations for
dogs can you bring up uh representative
buo I hope I pronounced that
right representative if you can unmute
[Music]
and can you hear me now we can go ahead
representative thank you for coming
in thank you Mr the chairman uh for the
record my name is Tom buo and I am a
representative from Carol County
District 2 I appear today to introduce
House Bill
387 which I sponsored at the request of
a constituent I recognized that my
constituent had done a tremendous amount
of research and she had even written out
the language for the proposed bill so
therefore I felt obligated to sponsor
the bill for her I explained to her that
I know nothing about this issue and I
would not be able to testify in support
of the bill or to answer any questions
about the issue therefore I request that
you call on Maryanne omara to explain
the intent of the bill and to answer any
questions you may have thank you Mr
chair
thankes
bring thank you representative buo um
good morning members of the House ladies
and gentlemen convulsive seizure
reverse sneezing aggression fear of
bright things violent itching
inflammation of the heart muscle and
chronic digestive issues these are just
a few of the known reactions in dogs to
the rabies vaccine the ones I have
personal experience with with time
finances and the right Veterinary
support some of these dogs lives can
improve giving them a chance at a
somewhat normal life until their next
vaccination in New Hampshire sure we are
fortunate to have the option to obtain
an exemption for these dogs however this
exemption comes with a price as the law
reads today K9 Sports daycare grooming
obedience classes and boarding kennels
are all out of the question for these
dogs as they shall be maintained in
strict rabies isolation muzzled on a
leash and under direct physical control
of an adult owner at all times when
outside as I did my research on how this
could be changed I was surprised at what
I found the current compendium States
within 28 days after initial vaccination
a peak rabies virus antibody tighter is
expected and the animal can be
considered immunized in all the years
that I have owned dogs I don't ever
recall this being suggested to me this
tells me that when done a titer is
accepted as proof of response it also
leads me to believe that there could be
any number of dogs who are
non-responders as babies is transmitted
through saliva I would be more concerned
about those dogs being out and about in
public my goal in taking on this project
was to remove the rabies isolation
stipulation for vaccinated dogs with
medical exemptions it was not my intent
nor is it my responsibility to put
owners of non-responders in that same
difficult position I respectfully
request that lines 7 through 16 be
modified to reflect that and would
welcome the opportunity to provide input
the compendium also States under post
exposure management dogs and cats that
are overdue for a booster vaccination
and that have appropriate documentation
of having received a USDA licensed
rabies vaccine at least once previously
should immediately receive Veterinary
Medical Care for assessment wound
cleansing and booster vaccination the
animal should be kept under the owner's
control and observed for 45 days again
we fortunate as the state of New
Hampshire does not require immediate
euthanasia for these dogs if a dog is
considered immunized after initial
vaccination if nonresponders are not
identified if dogs with an out-of-date
vaccination are not required to be kept
in rabies isolation why is this imposed
on dogs with medical exemptions who must
have had at least one rabies vaccination
to have had a
reaction should I have an emergency that
would require boarding my dogs they
would need to have a rabies booster one
has congestive heart failure the other
chronic digestive issues and violent
itching both have documented reactions
to previous rabies boosters both have
tighter levels well above the minimal
requirement it is my job to keep my dog
safe from harm I'm trying to do that by
changing this law I did receive a couple
of email queries um and if I may I'd
like to address those now um one was
concerned about standardized titer
testing and the variations of results
from Lab to lab I'm familiar with only
two Labs that do rabes titers for
Animals Atlanta Health Associates and
Kansas State University I know that Dr
John Rob offers to have titers done
through KSU for a reasonable cost I
believe due to the number of samples he
submits the rfit test can be run as
modified or endpoint which is more
accurate more expensive but not
necessarily required a modified test
should be sufficient to determine that
there has been a response to the vaccine
if we are to require that titers be done
to validate a response it would make the
most sense to stick to one lab for all
samples given the quantity that would be
submitted there could possibly be a
financial advantage as for standard
results an article on the avma website
discussing pre-exposure vaccination for
veterinarians includes the following the
acip recommends titer on a schedule of
every two years to assess protective
immunity with a single injection booster
vaccination recommended if the titer
level is below 1 to5 serum dilution the
World Health organization's rabies titer
cut off is higher The Who recommends
that a single booster Rab's vaccination
be given when the titer drops below 0.5
IUS per ml by the
rfit that said there is no established
protective Tighter and post exposure
prophylaxis is still necessary after
known
exposure according to the Kansas State
Veterinary diagnostic laboratory tighter
levels
of um title levels or values equal to or
above
0.5 iuml provide evidence of a robust
immune response after rabies vaccination
although the presence of antibodies
after vaccination is important a
specific level above 0.5 iuml does not
give complete Assurance of protection
against the disease in every individual
because there are other immunological
factors involved in the protection from
rabies infection however an overview of
rabies challenge studies indicates
rabies virus neutralizing antibody
levels equal to or above
0.5 provides at least equal Assurance of
protection as does current vaccination
status that's that hopefully answers
that question um there were
another there were a lot of concerns um
about what I'm proposing
and I think I've answered a number of
them um with my testimony and also that
response all right thank you Mr Mayor
why don't we open it up to some
questions from the members of the
committee representative bden uh thank
you Mr chair and and thank you so much
for testifying today and for taking my
question um I noticed that the paragraph
that's being amended applies to dogs
cats and ferrets but the amendment or
the um the Bill only addresses that uh
that all this tighter testing would
apply to dogs is there a reason why cats
and ferrets are not included in this
bill well I have to say it's simply
because I'm a dog person and I don't
have enough information how it affects
cats or
ferrets thank
you any other questions from the
committee
representative
sfus thank you uh Mr chairman um this Dr
Rob that you talked about he um
he he testified before us the last time
this bill came up and he testified that
he had lost his his ability to give
rabies shots because he was not giving
the full dose and um I was wondering if
his if his privileges have been
restored I'm not sure about that I know
that there's been a lot of
controversy I read Dr Rob's
information and I you know I I read it
and I think about it I mentioned him
simply because he is offering this
service to P owners and you don't have
to be a client of his your own
veterinarian can pull the blood have it
spun all Dr Rob is offering is that you
get it submitted through his account
which keeps the cost to a minimum for
pet owners because having titers done
can run into the high
numbers all
right any other questions from the
committee
screen all right thank you uh
z uh represented boo you had your hand
up did you have a follow-up question or
testimony that you wanted to
offer uh no I did not uh no all right
thank you
did you have a yes thank you Mr chair
and so M thank you so much for coming
and testify today um I'm interested to
know more
about the exemption if if animal say we
did have some sort of way in which to
really determine accurately tighter
accounts um
what what
how for any animal that did not where
that did uh have have a a tighter amount
and could be Exempted from getting a r
shot would you what would you recommend
for the current exemption the animal has
to be uh in isolation and under certain
conditions and
how would you see that they would be
treated any differently than any other
animal I believe that a dog that has a
current medical exemption should be
treated the same as a dog with an out
ofd rabies
vaccination um which is exactly what I
referenced from the compendium they
don't need to be in isolation they
simply need to be boostered um I don't
understand why it's any different for a
dog who's had a reaction it seems a
little bit
severe for me to have to put my dog in
rabies
isolation excuse me when clearly they
have protection from rabies just by the
fact that I had their tighter done last
year and they were way above the
0.5
limit so I don't understand why they
need to be an i ol ation they've done
nothing wrong other than to have a
reaction to a very difficult
vaccination
um they should just be allowed to be
dogs and I think you'll find that
anybody who's had a dog who's had a
severe reaction isn't going to be
letting their dogs out running free and
bothering other people most of those
dogs don't really want that kind of a
life after that that's providing they
can even recover from the reactions that
they've
had I hope that helps thank you uh
representative Highland I'll recognize
you for a
question thank you for taking my
question uh Mr chair I was just trying
to get up to speed a little bit on um is
this bill a preventative measure or is
this in response to an increase in
rabies in the community
thank
you for me it's neither for me it's it's
having a dog who's had a severe reaction
spending hours lots of money lots of
worry helping that dog get back to
somewhat normal who now can never go
anywhere or do anything I can't take my
dog to a training class I can't really
go anywhere with my dog unless it's on a
six-foot lead or muzzled um I used to
compete in Dog Sports I used to love
taking my dogs to training classes just
for fun just for the social aspect of it
and yes I understand things have changed
that way right now but you know what's
to say that in the future I get another
dog who also ends up with a a reaction
to the rabies vaccine I choose to get a
waiver I now can no longer do anything
with my dog
lots of people get dogs to compete
that's what their hobby is Dog Sports
suddenly they're no longer allowed to do
that so it's simply to allow these dogs
the freedom that dogs with a lapsed
vaccine have there's really no
difference in in my
view thank you representative Kaplan did
you have a question yes I did thank you
Mr chair for taking my question and uh
thank you Mr for coming in um I didn't
know that some dogs uh you know got
allergic reactions to the rabies vaccine
I suppose that's it's U uh you know not
that surprising because those things do
happen with vaccinations but I sounds
like it's more frequent than we than we
assumed but the way I'm reading your uh
your your bill as proposed it seems to
be mandating all dog owners to receive
this tighter test after getting the
rabies vaccination and it sounds fam
your testimony that that wasn't your
intent is that correct actually I would
love to see um dog owners have a tighter
done after the initial vaccination just
to ensure that there is protection there
and that is in the
compendium and I think that the way it's
written in the compendium is a bit
confusing because there's nothing else
in any of our laws that say that that
we'll accept titer but in that
particular section that's what it says
that you have to that unless somebody
knows some magical way to to tell that a
dog has received protection from that
first vaccination the only way to tell
is to do a Tighter and there are a
number of reasons why a dog wouldn't
respond to the vaccine
um followup question if I may Mr chair
yes
go you uh Mr Mayor do you know how
common it is for dogs not to respond to
to a vaccine I mean it seems like from
what I know of of most vaccines in
humans that's a pretty rare occurrence
so I mean is it is it more common than
we
think I think it's a lot more common
than we think and I think one of the
biggest problems is
that the reactions are not recognized as
such for example
I have one dog who when she had her last
rabies
booster in
2008 within hours after returning home
she started frantically chewing on
herself nothing nothing would help
so if I called my local vet they would
just probably put her on some sort of
medication
that may or may not help it's not fixing
it it's not taking that problem away
it's just a Band-Aid
so how many other dogs out there are
itching how many other dogs have
seizures that are like just out of the
blue for what most people say well just
for no reason I don't know what happened
he just had a seizure but you can
usually track a lot of those things back
to after the rabies
vaccination unfortunately it just
doesn't seem to be an issue
for most people um maybe it's only an
issue for me but I've seen it enough
times that I know it's a problem I used
to be an obedience trainer I used to be
a pet Behavior counselor the number of
dogs that I
saw with behavior issues that were just
clinical I'm gonna I'm gonna interrupt
keep you to the question because we have
several more hands up so our
representative
Kennedy thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um just a
curiosity what is the cost of the
tighter test and um as
Klan mentioned before with the language
of the bill um talking about tighter
tests being more vastly used
mentioning that wanting them after a dog
gets the vaccine to know that they um
are
responding U what the cost would be and
then how much that would be to the
owners I'd see possibly unnecessary
costs if they've already paid for the
vaccine and then now you're asking for
them to do a tighter test on
that the cost is going to vary depending
on whoever your V Vetinarian is they're
going to charge you whatever they feel
they should be charging you um that's
the benefit that Dr Rob is offering pet
owners his charge for um having a
tighter sent to KSU is
$55 as opposed to a 100 plus that you
would pay if you went just through your
local
vet all right thank you representative
Duty
uh yes thank you for taking my question
uh I'm a cat owner not a dog owner so
this um I apologize if this is naive but
if a uh dog cannot have a rabies uh shot
and gets Exempted does that mean uh what
does that mean in terms of their ability
to run in the yard if you have a closed
in yard uh do they still have to be on a
leash do they still have to be muzzled
or are they free to roam at that point
well the way the is written today
it I can interpret it as if my
dog has a waiver anytime I take it
outside it needs to be muzzled and on a
lead I'd like to think that it would be
okay to let my dog run in my fenced in
yard um but as far as walking my down my
road my sorry my dog down the road I
live in the middle of nowhere yet
technically my dog should still be mus
buled and on a 6 foot Le so it does
really restrict and it's anytime the dog
is outside which means if you take your
dog anywhere it has to be muzzled and on
a lead so there really is quite a bit of
loss of
Freedom all right thank you
uh representative
Highland thank you Mr chair for taking
my question I just was wondering within
the research if there if you found
precedent for this in other states and
how they're handling if they are if
there's any other example of using the
antibod tests within 30 days elsewhere
that we might see um you know the system
how they're using it how they
implemented it um that's that type of
thing thank you unfortunately I don't
know of any I do know that the state of
Delaware just recently passed a bill
accepting titer as opposed to just
vaccination in Li of vaccination so
there is a precedent there um that's not
what I'm suggesting with this but um I
don't know of any other states that are
actively accepting titer just as proof
of
response thank you representative hola
did you have a question I did but it was
okay OB thank you all right uh
representative Murray is
recognized thank you Mr chair for taking
my question and thank you also also for
taking my question so one of the things
I'm hearing um some conversation around
an Avenue of of uh utilizing a
uh a a testing laboratory outside of the
State of New Hampshire but I'm curious
how many facilities with uh veterinarian
facilities within the state of New
Hampshire um do you have an idea of um
what Laboratories they may utilize in
tighter testing or would I I'm just you
keep referencing this Dr Rob and sending
the tests in that direction would a
licensed New Hampshire veterinarian in
are you suggesting they would then send
their samples to this doctor I'm a
little bit confused no if you were to go
through Dr Rob you would take your dog
to your own veterinarian ask them to
draw the blood and spin it and then you
would have already printed off and paid
for the test through Dr Rob's website
you only need to stick your paperwork
and the vial of serum into the mail and
send it off to Kansas State
University if you were to have the
tighter test done or done the do the
whole process through your own local
veterinarian they would do the same
thing they would draw the blood spin it
and they would fill out the paperwork
they would send it to Kansas
State the the difference is the cost
that that's it followup if I may uh sure
followup
represent thank you um do you know if if
choosing one Avenue or the other
um would have any um responsibility
placed on the veterinarian if you chose
to send it through the license of
another doctor does that affect the
veterinarian who is assessing your
animal do they have a burden of
responsibility to then communicate and
any way with the other
person um Dr
Rob you know I'm not really sure I think
that's a question for a veterinarian but
I know that I did have a tighter done
through Dr Rob because I wanted to try
it and see what happened um and it was
fine my local vet had no problem with
that I did rtier my dogs because the one
with Dr Rob was just um a basic one and
I wanted the full numbers on my dog
so I had it done through my own vet
simply because it was easier it's like
One-Stop
shopping all right thank you any further
questions uh representative cont thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question um so to get a tighter test it
sounds like we we have to draw
blood get and if you're using Dr
Rob you keep mentioning who drawing the
blood my local veterinarian was more
than willing to draw blood spin it and
hand it over to me so that I could send
it off to KSU with the label that I had
from my transaction with Dr
Rob follow up yep thank you Mr chair
so I guess you know we're hearing
testimony saying that the local vet can
do it or Dr Rob can do it but
technically your local vet has to handle
the no matter what is that correct
yes thank
you all right any further questions
seeing none we thank you for your
testimony thank you next we will P pull
up uh Joyce
aravella uh Mr chair could I um could I
just ask a Qui quick question if you
before we proceed certainly go ahead
representative um so I was just
wondering how many uh how many people we
have more testifying and uh if you could
just if it's a relatively short number
could you let us know who they are sure
we have uh four excuse me three
additional testimonies Joyce aravel
andreula Ferrari from the and uh Stacy
over from the American
C thank you you're welcome all right uh
isella are you up
yet can't find her
Miss Aral if you're out there could you
put your hand up please so we can find
you right I don't see that all right
moving on uh next we'll pull up Angela
Ferrari from dog owners of the Granite
State good morning can you hear me we
can go ahead Angela okay wonderful um
thank you to the committee for listening
to my testimony today I'm here
representing dog owners of the Granite
State uh who opposes this bill um we
want to thank Maryann for her thoughtful
attempt to solve her concern for her
dogs and we do understand that there are
reactions to the rabies
vaccine however as this bill is written
um although intended to allow Provisions
for dogs that do not adequately react to
Arab vaccine it actually adds
unnecessary and unproven testing
following rabies vaccines for all dogs
in New Hampshire so if you think about
all of the dogs that have to get a
rabies vaccine and that is everyone
who's going to get their dogs licensed
um you know with few exemptions out
there they will all need to follow up
that vaccine with a tighter um as I
think we're all starting to understand
that is costly not just for the test
itself self which needs to be shipped
out to Kansas State I looked it up and
that test runs a minimum of
$90 um and then we have to add in the
shipping fees and the cost for your
veterinarian to draw the blood so that
that test can be sent out so you know
we're looking at over
$100 over that in addition to the cost
of the previously done rabies vaccine
and this is just to check to see if this
has indeed had enough antibodies to
react to That vaccine what happens if
the V the tighter comes back too low now
the dog needs to be revaccinated so
there's another $50 to
$60 and additionally an additional
tighter would need to be done uh which
is as we stated over $100 there so we're
looking at close to
$400 just for two rounds if a dog did
not
um accept that initial rabies vaccine
and that's putting a lot of burden on
the dog owners of New Hampshire um as
far as you know we're aware we have not
been seeing a rise in rabies cases in
the pet Community where dogs are not uh
accepting these vaccines um so we do
feel that our current method of
requiring that rabies vaccine is
sufficient and working properly and the
added burden of the these additional
costs for titering would probably drive
down adherence to rabies vaccines in
general um not every person can even
afford that additional cost for one
round of rabies titering let alone two
or potentially even more and that's just
for one dog um you know many of us have
multiple dogs and that cost would get
very
expensive um I also want to mention that
I think it's it's it's hard to require
everyone to do titering when titering
isn't even approved um in Lo of
revaccinated so for standard tighter
testing for example um when my dogs need
to get their parvo booster or distemper
booster we use tighter testing to check
their antibodies that's very standard
for those type of diseases which are
very different than
rabies um and we can do that in lie of
revaccinated them because if they have
the antibodies it shows that they do not
actually need to be
revaccinated however in the case with
rabies um looking at the compendium of
animal rabies prevention and control
which was referenced earlier by uh
Maryanne they are saying that titer do
not directly correlate with protection
because other immunological factors also
play a role in preventing rabies and our
abilities to measure and interpret those
other factors are not welldeveloped
therefore evidence of circulating rabies
virus antibodies should not be used as a
substitute for current vaccination in
managing rabies exposure or determining
the need for booster vaccinations in
animals uh you can see that in some
additional quotes that I have in my
written testimony that was submitted but
I feel that you know until we can
actually trust the rabies tighter as an
option for replacing
revaccination that it doesn't have a
purpose to be written into law to
confirm whether a dog has accepted the
vaccine and may subsequently require an
additional one um the uh Maryanne excuse
me she mentioned that you know the
purpose of this bill was to try and
avoid vaccinating dogs who have
reactions to the vaccine I actually see
this bill as having potential to be over
vaccinating dogs if that tighter test
comes back low which isn't even proven
that it means the dog is truly not uh
covered by that initial rabies
vaccine later in the bill it does go on
to talk about those who are exempt um
and what the protocols would be and I do
think that that is an area that we could
dig into further because having dogs
quar ened muzzled not allowed off lead
things like that um because they have
had a reaction and have been given an
exemption I do agree that we do need to
do a little bit of work there but I
think until rabies vaccines and titers
um are proven and legally accepted we
should not be putting any requirement in
law for their use and we should revisit
this part of the law at that time once
they are approved um and I would be
willing to take any questions thank
you Angel sounds like we may have uh the
makings of another bill here that we'll
have to look at for another year any uh
any questions for Angela from the
committee uh representative Murray hi
yes thank you for taking my question and
thank you to miss Ferrari for taking my
question so my question is actually
around in addition to sort
of the information from the compendium
you stated do you have any concerns with
um potential you know um if a dog were
um to bite somebody would this would
this have any potential to maybe cause
undo anxieties or or or justly um
concern over needing um the a person to
be vaccinated themselves against rabies
for any reason
um that's generally my
question thank you for your question
question um if I if I understand it
correctly I I don't think that it would
cause any additional concern um current
law has been followed very well we have
not seen reason to make adjustments to
the law with concerns of dogs not
accepting that initial rabies vaccine
and their follow-ups um so I think you
know there might be a community that is
going to grow in concerns with the start
of these discussions happening about
these rabby titer being available um but
I think that there's just not enough
research and documentation that proves
that these titers are truly working that
we should be relying on them to that
extent one one more followup if I may Mr
chair sure go ahead follow um do you
thank you um do you know how long
roughly it would take to get a TI
response back even from one of these
facilities or Labs like in the event
that something did happen and there was
a question about the tighter levels um
how long does that process take do you
know so in my experience with different
Labs it varies um first you have to
remember that you need to get into your
vet so there's going to be the delay for
getting that appointment um nowadays you
know appointments are few and far
between with Co and everything we've
been dealing with so there there could
be a week delay there then you need to
get it shipped off so you're going to
probably overnight it so you're going to
have another day there and then you need
to make sure that the lab receives it
within their testing window um otherwise
there can be delays added for when they
will get to your sample in addition to
you know other samples that they might
have ahead of yours I have had it take
over a week to get results for other
standard testing that I've done I've
never had a tighter test for rabies done
so I can't speak to it specifically but
just know that it isn't you know a super
fast
turnaround representative
Bixby uh thank you Mr chair thank you uh
Miss Miss faray for taking my question
um I uh a couple of questions I and I
would like to be able to ask these
questions
uh the State Vet because um I I think he
might I'm I'm I'm sure he has the
answers but you might have the answers
and he's not going to be able to speak
today uh so I was wondering if you have
any sense of how prevalent uh rabies is
in wildlife and and what what the risks
are for uh animals getting bitten and
having it transferred to
pets unfortunately I do not have the
answer to that um I have not person
ever heard of anyone whose dog has or
cat Etc has been bitten and had a
concern for rabies um and I have a
pretty wide Network within New Hampshire
of dog owners due to the dog owners of
the Granite State group um but that
doesn't mean that there aren't some out
there all right I I I know that he last
year he had mentioned that there was a
case of a a sheep who had been bitten by
something and uh contracted rabies in
the town next to mine so that was um so
apparently it is out there uh and if I
may have a follow up yes go ahead um so
uh you T you brought up some information
about the uh the compendium suggesting
that there's not um uh that the titer
are not really reliable at this moment
and um I'm not sure how much you know
about the way that the the U the immune
system works but Mr do in his testimony
Dr Crawford mentioned something about uh
there being different types of uh
immunity one uh from cell that goes that
goes along with cells and one that goes
along with antibodies in that that are
in the body fluids and that those it's
not really clear how those two work yet
uh but you might have immunity from one
but um even if the other doesn't show up
uh do you know anything about
that I do not know uh scientifically I
have heard you know that there are the
two different types of immunity And in
regards to how I mentioned parvo and
this temper titers those are widely
accepted and very reliable um versus the
rabies titer are not yet
because there is they're a different
type of disease um so maybe those are
the two type of things that cause them
to be different um but hopefully Dr
Crawford will be able to elaborate on
that for you thank
you all right thank you unfortunately Dr
Crawford isn't going to be able to
testify today he sent in an email he has
h a board of Veterinary meeting and so
he's unable to be in two places at once
but we'll have to help have him work on
his Zoom skills and have one in each
year uh is there any further questions
for uh Angela before we let her
go well I can't see anymore I just k
kick from the webinar so you have any
hands
up uh representative muray did you have
another
question
no any further questions from the
committee all right thank you Angela we
appreciate your
testimony next we will uh bring up Stacy
o ber from the American Kennel
Club good morning everyone thank you for
a moment to speak in opposition to house
387 as you know the American Kennel Club
is a 135 year old nonprofit organization
that's a recognized and trusted expert
in K9 Health breeding training and
responsible dog ownership um our clubs
have raised and our affiliate K9 Health
Foundation has funded more than $59
million in can9 health research um I'm
grateful that Miss omera has reflected
on the importance of uh strengthening
the human can9 bond by participating in
uh performance events and other dog
sport activities
AKC sanctioned 141 events in New
Hampshire back in 2019 in which more
than 24,000 dogs participated um I just
want to not repeat anything that you've
heard and a lot of thoughtful questions
from committee members which I
appreciate I just wanted to acknowledge
that there is no cure for rabies and
it's deadly if it's contracted um and
it's a zoonotic disease so it's
transmissible among mammals including
humans um that being said I think that
there has been uh growing questions
around this idea of rabies titers
antibody
titers and my understanding is that the
National Association of state public
health veterinarians review that
compendium on an annual basis and so
rather than amending state law which all
of the states laws reflect what the
compendium which is the expertise of our
state public health veterinarians um
rather than a
Stacey I think we lost you oh can you
hear me yes I got you back now
sorry the forum for
this since they review the compendium
annually and look at the scientific
literature um again
the there was one question about or a
point made that some states are
requiring rabies virus antibodies and so
I do have a link to the compendium in my
written testimony for you all on page
four of the compendium um at subsection
11 I just want to read one sentence to
you it says some jurisdictions require
evidence of vaccination and rabies virus
antibodies for animal importation
purposes so that's the limited use that
I see in the compendium when I reviewed
it in anticipation of drafting testimony
for this morning thank
you thank you Stacy any questions from
the
committee all right not see oh
representative Bixby just put his hand
up go ahead representative Bixby yeah I
I was just wondering um uh this is a
question asked before and the person and
Miss Ferrari wasn't able to answer it
and I wonder if you have any data on the
prevalence of uh of rabes in wildlife
and you know and how that creates a risk
for uh
pets sure I can say that I've not seen a
lot of transmission by Wildlife to
domestic pets what I have seen from the
perspective of AKC which monitors what
goes on across the country is isolated
incidents of uh dogs that are
transported into this country from other
countries uh back in 2019 for instance
the United States Centers for Disease
Control issued a ban on importing
animals from Egypt because there were
two uh cases tracked where animals that
were imported into the country uh were
infected with rabies and ended up in
shelters and transmitted that way um so
I've seen some examples of where tra
rabies has been transmitted into the
country but no incidents with regard to
exposure to
Wildlife at least not
recently I think the last uh case I saw
in Rhode Island was a cat back in 2013
representative that had been bit and uh
needed to be quarantined and the owner
unlawfully crossed the state border from
Massachusetts into Rhode Island with an
infected cat that was supposed to be
quarantined um after after a bite but
that was the most recent case that I
came across thank
you all right thank you representative
Murray yes thank you Mr chair for taking
my question and thank you Miss Ober for
taking my question isn't it true that um
vaccines generally for rabies are
preventative and prophylactic in nature
because once um any symptom would show
as you noted um you it's incurable at
that point correct that's my
understanding yes I've heard uh
presentations from State veterinarians
where they H could not overemphasize the
importance of prevention because there
is no cure for
rabies thank you it it's it's a deadly
death is inevitable if contracted that's
correct thank you all right thank you
any further questions for Miss
obber all right seeing them thank you
Miss over appreciate your
testimony my pleasure is there anyone
else from that would like to testify on
this bill please raise your
hand all right uh commissioner Jasper
has his hand up so would you bring him
up
commissioner Jasper are you able to
unmute excuse me hope can you hear me
now we can go ahead for the record I am
Sean Jasper commissioner of the
Department of Agriculture markets and
food I appreciate the opportunity to
testify
uh in opposition to the bill this
morning two previous speakers have said
much of what I wanted wanted to um you
do have the email from Dr Crawford which
really goes into into the
detail uh of what needs to be said I I
just think I need to remind everyone
hopefully I don't though um that the
reason we have our pets vaccinated is
for human protection not for the prote
ction of the pets primarily it's to
protect the public from rabies and
you've heard that titer is not an
indication one way or another as to
whether there is um immunity and
protection from rabies as much as a one
of the previous speakers would like you
to believe that it that it is the study
that we waited for last year came out
and it did conclude that the current
study was not able to Pro Pur prove a
detective um rabies tighter standard and
that was the purpose of the study so in
the the very study that intended to
prove the case was unable to do that um
I I think we all understand that it
would be unwise at this time to pass a
bill that does not have the scientific
proof behind it and um I guess that's
really all I need to say at this time
and would urge you to uh find this bill
an expedient to leg late I'd be glad to
answer any questions that I might be
able
to thank you commissioner representative
B thank you Mr chair and thank you to
the commissioner for taking my question
I'm not sure if you're the right person
to ask this question but I just thought
of it while you spoke do you happen to
know the cost of post exposure
prophylactic treatment in humans for
rabies exposure no I I don't um I know
it's changed quite a bit over over the
years but um
uh it is not a a
cheap uh process and certainly um you
know once a person has
rabies um it's it's a very serious
n serious uh disease and um the fact is
that we need to continue to do what
state law is um is required to be done
at this at this point and as unfortunate
it is for animals and the owners of the
animals who may have um reactions to the
rabies shot I I really believe that um
that is secondary to the concern of
having um humans exposed to possible
rabies thank you thank you uh
representative Aaron thank you Mr
chairman and thank you commissioner for
coming today to uh
testify in our hearing today U there was
some discussion
just brief discussion regarding the
exemption of animals who have had
negative reactions to rabies
vaccination and you know pet owners who
opt for this exemption through the state
that maran's
office um they've expressed the desire
to see some sort of easing of the manner
by which their animals can be
kept do you for see um you know any
way in which we might be able to proceed
with that uh in a very safe manner so
that these animals don't have to be
um you know so
stringently uh especially in a
controlled environment in their own
home is that something that we might be
able to discuss at some point with u
with Dr
Crawford that might be a subject
thank you for the question that might be
a subject for uh another bill at another
another time I certainly don't think
that it is
currently um I think we'd have to have
more information as to how many of these
these animals there are out there and I
don't have that information I do know
that the reaction is extremely rare and
that's according to the um
compendium and you know again we're
talking about public health here
and obviously a dog that is kept
isolated and not in an area where
they're exposed to wild animals have a
much uh less likely chance of developing
rabies but um we need would need to have
some serious discussion about this do a
lot more research um so while we're
always glad to have discussions about
these things this um bill is not the
vehicle for that in my opinion and
again all right thank you any additional
questions for commissioner
Jasper seeing none thank you
commissioner we appreciate your
testimony thank you for the
opportunity is there anyone else that
would like to testify on this
bill we have Nancy Holmes Nancy did you
want to come
on yes this should work am I unmuted now
you're are on go ahead Nancy okay great
Nancy hes I forgot to introduce myself
earlier and of course I'm going to have
dog background for your amusement um I I
have a couple of things as um
commissioner Jasper said this is about
human health um as much as I empathize
with Miss Amara's situation with her
dogs um this is about keeping people
safe to keep people safe you want to
increase the compliance with rabies
vaccination not decrease it I believe
that requiring every dog owner to pay
for titers um which are pretty much not
conclusive of anything um is not going
to increase compliance it's going to
decrease it um in my written testimony I
have a quote from the CDC about
serological titers for rabies titers do
not directly correlate with protection
because that immunological factors also
play a role in preventing r babies um
and the ability to measure those is um
not developed therefore evidence of in
um circulating rabies virus antibodies
should not be used as a substitute for
current vaccination and managing rabies
exposures are determining the need for
booster vaccinations in animals so the
CDC says no and I kind of believe them
um the other thing is that we have a
mechanism in place right now where you
go in and at like three to four months
you get your puppy vaccinated for
rabies it known that that might not
completely cover it so that before the
dog is a year old you get a second
vaccination to increase the response to
um the rabies virus um so we've already
got a situation in place where we're
we're planning for is a potential for a
few dogs not to be immunized with that
first shot so you go for a second one
and then you I believe the next series
is you get the next vaccine a year after
that second one and then after that you
can do a three-year vaccine um there is
um uh representative Bixby was asking
about rabies we have both Fox and
raccoon rabies as far as I know in the
state and um I know there are situations
where animals have been exposed I know
the situations where humans have been
exposed exposed to wild animals with
gravies um I think the most recent one I
can remember is the coyote that the
father had to beat off of his little kid
um I personally have seen a raccoon in
the middle of the street attacking car
tires as they went by that was a sick
animal that was most likely in my
opinion rabies um you know the other
thing is should this go forward and dogs
be able to go out in public without a
muzzle without being on a leash be
boarded be in groups and so on without
that rabies vaccine um is it going to be
the owner's responsibility to notify all
the people who may come in contact with
this animal that their dog is not
immunized against rabies um what kind of
impact is that going to have on Doggy
Daycare workers on people who Bard
animals and and so on I just don't think
it's safe I mean I certainly wouldn't
want my dogs going to even uh a dog part
situation where unmuzzled unvaccinated
um against rabies dogs was was there uh
is simply for the safety of the dogs and
the people who are also there um I'm
looking to see if I had anything else I
had my notes for for um um you know the
uh the only the only other thing I had
was that um I think everybody who's
spoken against this bill as I am um is
taking into account the best interests
of the most animals and the most people
I have a great deal of empathy for Miss
Amara not being able to compete with her
dogs but lack of rabies vaccination is
not the only thing that would keep
somebody from doing that and you still
keep and love the dogs and comply
whatever their needs are whether it be
they've ripped a cruciate ligament or or
something else so saying well I can't
compete in sports with my dogs because
they haven't had their rabies vaccine um
I don't think that is is valid um you
know I think this bill needs to be ited
and I'd be happy to answer any
questions thank you Miss Holmes any
questions from the
committee all right see none we
appreciate your testimony yes all right
that's the last hand we have so I will
this time remember to read the blue
sheet as I forgot to on the last bill so
we have uh 87 people signed in one in
support excuse 88 signed in one in
support one opposed and one
neutral all right with that I'm going to
close the hearing on uh HB 387 and we
have about one minute we're gonna open
the next one on
HB
[Music]
322 e
all right it is 11 o'clock I'm going to
open the hearing on House Bill
322 I do not see representative
testerman in our group if you're there
representative could you please raise
your hand
right not see I'm going to ask
representative Aaron to introduce hpit
322 and act requiring a color photo of a
dog cat or parret on a rabies
vaccination
certificate thank you Mr
chair as a courtesy to the sponsor of
this bill House Bill
322 would like to introduce this bill it
requires that a color photograph of the
dog cat or
feret on
the
documents
question all right representative Aon I
appreciate you representative B uh thank
you Mr chair if the sponsor is not able
to be here
who should we ask questions uh about the
bill
to I obviously not not representive Aon
I I think you probably have to ask them
of the folks that are testifying as we
go forward okay thank you very you're
very welcome so we'll uh bring up back
up Nancy
[Music]
Holmes oh aren't I lucky and aren't you
guys lucky here I am again welcome back
I sent in sent in written testimony on
this in which I included a couple of
pictures for for your amusement um one
is of the same dog at different ages
you'll notice that the dog looks
completely different we won't discuss
how the dog looked once groomed down to
have less coat than that the other
picture I sent in was a pair of cats one
is my orange cat and one is my cat that
when I got him he looked like a tabby
Siamese not long after that he darkened
up because he has a Siamese Gene
although he was a barn cat and
those pictures of the white cat and the
dark tabby cat are the same
animal um my point in all of this is
that pictures on a rabies vaccination
certificate are absolutely useless um I
defy most people to be able to tell the
difference between um any number of
different dogs that are the same color
and the same sex um most most of you may
have at some point or other tripped over
a dog show on TV or it maybe actually
watched one in person um one of the
comments I frequently hear or heard at
dog shows was how is the judges telling
them apart now you have to have a
trained eye to be able to do that I'm
going to give you one more anecdote um
just to let you understand how how
useless this process would be um never
mind clly but just useless I had a young
woman come and visit my house with a
puppy of the breed that I raised um she
asked if she could put the puppy down to
play with my dogs I had some similar age
and some older ones at at that time
after a few minutes the owner in a panic
a asked me but which one is mine now
this is a puppy she'd had for six weeks
and putting it down in a bunch of
similar dogs she could not pick her
puppy out of the pack fortunately I
could although I was tempted to say no
no it's that one I didn't you know I let
her go go home with her puppy um but uh
you know this is the problem is people
never mind people in person can't tell
one dog from another never mind in a
picture so I don't see any point to it
and then you go into all of the cost to
the veterinarian which will be passed on
to the owner um and you know again I'm
right back to raby's compliance we want
more people to comply with getting their
animals rabies vaccinations rabies is
here in New Hampshire we don't want to
price it out of the reach of the average
person I personally can't imagine trying
to run a rabies clinic with with uh you
know 25 people in line waiting for their
animal to get a shot and then try to get
pictures of all these animals in some
fire station um it just doesn't seem
practical to me I think this bill really
needs to be itl and I would be happy to
take any
questions you Misses any questions from
the committee representative NOA thank
you ch
thank you for taking my question do you
do you are you uh do you happen to know
the impetus for requiring photos I'm I'm
not a little clear on exactly why a
photo would be
necessary um I know I don't know if uh
Miss obber is going to testify or not
but I um I did ask the the primary
sponsor of the bill if he could explain
what the purpose was because I'm sure it
had a good purpose you know and a good
intent but um Miss Ober did say that she
had heard back from the primary sponsor
and it was supposedly in response to a
um um a constituent concern that they
may have gotten the wrong rabies
certificate for their animal um and so I
I think that was it I think most
veterinarians are pretty good about
making sure the right um certificate
goes with the right pet um and uh the
only thing I could see is maybe it had
been a sales situation where the person
wasn't sure but my problem is in in I
say 9 99.9% of the time nobody could say
for sure that the picture was of the
same animal that the person had sitting
in front of them anyway so I don't think
it's it's a valuable um addition to the
certificate thank
you additional questions from his homes
uh representative
Murray representative muray you're
muted thank you very much um thank you
Mr Sher for taking my question and thank
you Miss Holmes for taking my question
um in reviewing the piece of legislation
do you have any idea of um what what the
method would be for attaching this um
photograph and also what size of
photograph might be required I'm wasn't
entirely
clear you know I have to say I I have no
idea what the intent was my my Su um
original impression was that probably
probably they're expecting a color print
out of the picture on the Raby
certificate I don't get an actual
physical form when I get a Raby
certificate my vet prints one off of
their computer system and that's the
same as what is sent to my town um there
are I'm sure official RAB certificates
that you can get for veterinarians who
who don't do it that way um like perhaps
at a rabies clinic I just haven't had
one of those in a long time I suppose
you could print a picture and staple it
um but you know what the intent is um
what the size would be what requirements
there might be for
clarity um you know the ability of the
person to take a picture if any of you
have tried to take pictures of your pets
you know they can be
non-cooperative um so I I I don't really
know I just can't see it as having any
added value to the rabies certificate
you know and uh un unless you have that
purple and pink polka doted dog that
nobody else
had thank you thank you for
any further
questions representative Bon thank you
Mr chair and and thank you Miss Holmes
for uh taking the question um I I know
you know a little bit about technology
and and databases and whatnot and I'm
wondering the Bill's not exactly clear
but it it sounds like the the town clerk
may have to retain a copy of this of
this photo and I know a lot of towns are
are electronic these days I I imagine
that would dramatically incre increase
the amount of database storage capacity
that a town may have to have and I
imagine that would be pretty expensive
would you say that's probably correct
well in in the world of computers my
understanding is is that storage is the
cheapest cost of any um but yes it would
it would be an increased burden on the
towns to handle that I know the way that
my my veterinarian sends in um the rabes
certificates to my town is they put it
in the envelope and mail it and they may
at the end of the week mail all the ones
that go to my particular town from their
practice um so that you would be then
sitting there and um what happens is the
uh in my town anyway the as I follow the
procedure is the clerk enters the
information into um their database or
spreadsheet whichever way they're
working it now and then um the uh I
think the actual certificate it itself
is not retained there
um so I I can I can see this as just
being a little more stuff in the
landfill thank you thank you any
additional
[Music]
questions seeing none thank you Miss HS
thank you next we will bring up Angela
Ferrari from dog owners of the Granite
State who opposes the
Bill thank you can you hear me we can go
ahead Miss Ferrari great thank you all
uh for listening to me testify again on
HB 322 now um we defin dog owners at the
granite state opposes this bill as me
mentioned by the chairman uh we have
concerns about the potential for this
addition to the rabies vaccination to
drive up costs um there's going to be
additional time needed for veterinarians
to work into their visit to get this
photo they'll also need to have access
to a c camera colored printers ink and
of course storage space to maintain
these records whether that be with the
veterinarian the town clerk or whatnot
um as mentioned by Miss Holmes there is
so much similarity between cats dogs and
ferrets especially of the same breed
that we feel the photos would have a low
percentage of proving an animals
identity we also had some questions on
you know would this be just a photo of
the animal's head would that be from the
front or the side should it be of the
full body should the animal be standing
or sitting uh or would it depend on what
would prove the identity of the animal
and who would make that decision so I
think it could get very complicated with
inconsistencies of photos uh being taken
and used let alone for quality and
Clarity of those
photos we were trying to understand um
who the bill actually benefits and
ultimately still trying to understand
the problem that the bill is is trying
to solve so it is unfortunate that we
didn't have it introduced to get some of
that
Clarity I also uh lastly just wanted to
mention that I think it is a slippery
slope um wondering if this could
potentially lead to health certificates
requiring colored photos next and
knowing all of the discussions we've had
regarding the database for health
certificates um we could have costly
impacts there for the Department of
Agriculture markets and foods for
storing those addition
photos and with that I would be happy to
take any
questions do we have any questions from
Miss
Ferrari all right seeing none thank you
for your testimony thank
you uh Mr chair I have a just a question
for you um do we have anyone who is
listed as being testifying in
support uh no we do not
thank you not not testifying we have
three in support who signed in on the
blue sheet but there's no one no one
would be speaking in support that is
correct okay
thanks all right I have no further names
on the list is there anyone else I would
like to testify on the bill uh Miss
Holmes you have your hand up
again so so
sorry um I thought I had it lowered all
right thank you anyone else that would
like to uh testify on the
bill seeing no hands I will read the
blue sheet we have
uh see 81 in opposition three in support
and zero neutrals so I will close the
hearing on HB
322 okay it is 11:15 I think we will uh
I'm going to take about a five minute
recess and give everyone a chance to
stretch their legs then we're going to
resume at
11:20 and we will go into doing
executing some bills
Str
why it's so
C
for
e
e e
it's
all right see is at 11:20 we're going to
come back into exec session and we're
going to EXA House Bill
322 and I am looking to representative
kto for a motion Mr chair I'd like to
propose that we it
hb22 do I have a second second
representative bden seconds I recognize
rep representative conto to speak to her
motion uh thank you Mr chair
um this bill um adding a t photograph uh
would add
an additional cost to getting the raby's
vaccine and not only that is what we
heard in testimony is that um it's you
may not know there similar dogs that
look the same be in the same town or
even within the same family so you
really the pict really is not a good
identification um and
again this is a well I understand the
intention and it's well intention bill
but it is
unnecessary all right thank you any
additional comments concerns questions
from the
committee all right seeing none I'm
going to ask the uh clerk to call a
rooll on House Bill 322 with a
recommendation of itl Representative
Aaron
yeses yes representative fille yes
Davis yes represent Stapleton yes
representative mola yes represent
Kennedy yes represent Mason yes repres
sorn
yes represent Bixby yes sopus yes pres
Balden yes pres Duty
yes Murray yes
vinsky
yes Kaplan
yes
Highland
yes perz yes Mr chair yes motion passes
yes oh yes sorry uh any objections to
putting that on the Cent
C hearing none sorry I was doing my
paperwork all right the is ready we will
uh we will exact House Bill 387
[Music]
all right so we will be executing house
bille 387 and I am looking to
representative sakes for a
motion um yes Mr chairman I move um itl
on this bill all right do I have a
second uh representative Sor second it
all right thank you I have a motion to
itl in a second I'll recognize rep
representative sakes to speak to her
motion
um thank you this is the second time uh
we've heard this bill before the
committee and um it's not quite ready
for prime time yet and um the research
is just not
where we need it to be to make it move
forward at this time it has a huge
downside in the fact that rabies
transmission to humans is to is um
is is fatal and so we just need to uh
wait for the resarch to catch up on
this thank you any further discussion
from the
committee all right seeing none I will
ask the clerk to call the role on
uh House Bill 387 with a motion of itl
represent Aon yes
represent yes represent Vero yes Davis
yes
Yesa yes represent Kennedy yes represent
Mason yes repr Sor
yeses viby yes repr sopus
yes Bon yes Duty
yes maray
yes pres vinsky
yes Kaplan yes represent Highland
yes
Perez representative perz you're
muted thank you yes Mr chair yes motion
pass is 190
any uh any objection to putting putting
this on the consent
calendar seeing none that's what we'll
do next bill we will exec is uh House
Bill
250 get to cleric a minute she's
ready for the committee there is an
amendment to this bill you want to pull
it
up it's a Amendment 2021 d0350
right clerk is ready so we will uh open
the exec on House Bill
250 and I am going to move ought to pass
with Amendment
202-
3508 and I am looking for a
second and I will second that thank you
representative
Bixby and I guess I'll recognize myself
to speak
to so House Bill 250 seeks to uh well
actually I could speak the amendment
first I'm sorry so House Bill 250 seeks
to uh change some uh change the
requirements to 30 dogs 35 cats
and it also provides and that's for the
pet vendor regulations it also provides
for the moving the an exemption to allow
for uh anybody that has a situation
where every four years they are
in uh have not qualified to be a pet
vendor previously but find them
themselves in the situation perhaps with
a large litter that uh is going to put
them over the
threshold additionally this uh since
this bill is a replace all for the I
mean excuse me the amendment is a
replace all for the bill I guess I have
to actually speak to the whole thing so
it also looks to re um change the date
of registration period versus the
licensing period we had a lot
conversation on that portion especially
when we were hearing it and their
representative Balden brought up a valid
point about a date change that needed to
occur because we had the wrong incorrect
date so on line 32 you will see that
we've corrected the date to instead of
December 31st it is now June 30th which
aligns properly with the uh with the
correct period the final portion of this
bill is that uh puts a language into
statute that clarifies a zoning problem
that occurred back in June of the budget
in June of 19 that when this all of this
language was originally put in so what
this will do is it will put the zoning
changes back to excuse me the zoning
requirements back to what it was prior
to the change in 19 which was the will
of the legislature in the
bill so
with that that pretty much uh identifies
everything that's going on is there any
further questions and comments concerns
from the committee on house bill excuse
me on amendment
202- 0350 to
amendment to House Bill
250 all right seeing none then I'm going
to ask the clerk to call the role and we
have an ought to pass I mean an
amendment ought to pass Amendment today
21-35
[Music]
H yes represent Aron yes represent K yes
represent veril yes Davis yes Stapleton
yes represent MOA yes Kennedy yes Mason
yes s yes vix yes
sopus yes bden yes represent Duty yes
Murray yes vinsky yes
Kaplan
no represent
Highland yes repr Perez yes Mr chair yes
motion passes 181
all right then I will move to pass as
amended otpa on House Bill
250 with Amendment
202-
0350 I'm looking for a
second I will second that thank you
representative viby so it is moved and
seconded uh I don't really have a lot
more to add since the amendment was a
replace all to the entire bill I think I
covered everything when I explained the
amendment is there any further questions
concerns from the
committee all right seeing none I'm
going to ask the clerk to call the role
on House Bill 250 otpa with Amendment
202-
0350 represent yes
represent K yes represent bbo
yes Davis yes Stapleton yes MOA yes
Kennedy yes repr Mason yes sour
yes
yes yes Duty yes then Murray yes binsky
Kaplan
no Highland
yes Perez
yes chair yes
181 is there any objection to putting
this on the consent
calendar seeing
none for
next we will exact House Bill 366 when
the clerk is ready
[Music]
all right um we're going to EXA House
Bill 366 and I will look to
representative Kennedy for a
motion
moain
B all right we have a motion to retain
do I have a second yes representative
vinsky seconds thank you representative
so we have a motion in a second to
retain I will recognize representative
Kennedy to speak to her motion
I speak to make a motion to retain House
Bill
um that there more work to be
done this get
submitted thank you I would further add
that uh while this is my bill like we
recognize and I recognize I when I
introduced it that there there's more
work it's sort of a contentious Topic at
times you know because uh we have a lot
of animal
cruelty concerns that do occur and
oftentimes they are related to hoarding
and so we were seeking to find a
definition that would define that and
help the the animals that are taken into
custody during that and you know during
these situations and all the also help
law enforcement to find a smooth
transition through this mostly to help
the folks that suffer from hoarding
disease and as we heard a lot of
testimony there's many that do that find
themselves in these situations relating
to you know being in trouble with the
law and having situations where they're
not able to care for their animals
oftentimes it's no fault of their own
intentionally but it's a situation that
occurs related to their disease so I
think we need U some more input on this
from criminal justice as far as it's
going to relate to
how it moves through the system and how
law enforcement is able to uh determine
the part that would be placed on them
about deciding who was a order so for
that reason I support the
retain is there any additional comments
or questions from the committee uh
representative bixman yes uh thank you
for taking my comment um I just wanted
to um point out that I I thought that
during our public hearing on this we had
a very good discussion of the issues and
it sound it seemed like everyone was
really directed towards finding a
solution for the problem and uh it's
just the solution isn't quite uh
solidified yet so I'm I'm looking
forward to being able to working on this
further with uh uh in uh in it's
retained form and coming out with
something that uh can work in the uh
next year of the
session thank you
representative anyone else
all right seeing none I will ask the
clerk to call the rooll on House Bill
366 with a motion to
retain represent Baron yes represent K
yes represent Vero yes represent Davis
yeses Stapleton yes represent MOA yes
represent Kennedy yes represent Mason
yes s yes viby yes
sopus
yes bden yes representa Duty yes Murray
yes vinsky yes represent Kaplan yes
represent piland yes Perez yes Mr chair
yes motion pass is 190
okay and just as a reminder to the
committee because we're retaining it it
does not need a uh committee report and
it will not be on the count
[Music]
Mr chair I have a question yes go ahead
permission to proceed with a dog in my
lap as long as he's not on camera we're
fine
uh Mr chairman can I make a comment yes
go ahead
representative uh I just want I just
sent everybody a letter of support that
we received from an industry group uh
and this is going uh I'll be discussing
it when we exec HB
272 so if you get a chance to quickly
scan it during lunch hour um we'll be
ahead of the game thank you
actually I think we're at a point where
we're going to have to break for lunch
because uh this is the my intended
schedule going forward for the rest of
the day we have
[Music]
uh we have House Bill 437 that we're
hearing at
1M House Bill 367 that we're hearing at
1:30 and House Bill 413 that we're
hearing at 2
pm we will um I doubt we'll have much
time to EXA in between any of those
hearings where I only haven't scheduled
for a half hour but immediately
following the hearing at 2 pm we will be
executing the remaining bills and I
intend to exec
um House Bill
uh 272 right first right after the
hearing as a courtesy to representative
coner because he wanted to be available
and then we will exact House Bill 177
right after that so my best guess is
around 2:45 and then we'll proceed on
from there to the remaining bills that
we have so with that we're going to go
into recess until 100 p.m. and we will
be back for the hearing on House Bill
for
e
e e
what yes
s
representative Murray can you hear me
can you stand in as clerk on this next
bill because representative comto is the
uh Prime
sponsor Ken uh Which documents do you
need me to have up uh this will be House
Bill
437 okay thank you thank you um just a
note on that there's also an amendment
that got sent this
morning uh which should also be
available
yeah we don't have a physical copy yet
here uh I believe they're outside the
room maybe on the table I'm not sure if
you had the door closed but they might
be outside the room we looked there and
they're
not yeah we we seem to have an amendment
for election lava not for Ena okay um
what room are you in in 206 okay they
were delivered to 306 let me see if we
can uh get that
rectified
okay the outside 306 we can run up and
grab them uh if you don't mind that
would be great care it thank you should
we bring the for election law up there
because that's where they are yeah why
don't we do yeah I'd say so thank you so
much for that I appreciate
it yeah she takes up okay
good thank you
Christina Mr chair if you'll just give
me a moment then to
um am I just o
just um clerking for the hearing correct
yes okay thank
you I'm going to hold off just a couple
of minutes here and let um repa get back
with the amendment and then we'll get
started she's pretty fast she's back
okay I guess we are all set to go we
have everything place on our end so I
will open the hearing on House Bill
437 and I will recognize representative
coma to introduce the bill and
establishing a committee to study the
implementation of the Meat Inspection
program thank you Mr chair thank you
committee members um this bill is being
brought forth um to establish study
commit to study the shortage of animal
spotter processing facilities in New
Hampshire and the reason this is
important is it's about food security
for our uh constituents in New Hampshire
currently um if you want to take an
animal to slaughter and sell it to the
public you cannot get appointments until
2022 um and New Hampshire we only have a
certain amount of USDA facilities
currently in there and they are solid um
if you're a new farmer trying to get
into the business you're not going to
get an appointment um for at least a
year so it really is something that
needs to be addressed people have really
looked uh especially during the pandemic
about buying local food and um it's
creating an issue um I know Farmers that
have now since this been pic has started
that won't sell people from out of state
are calling up looking for meat and
they'll only sell to their existing
customers customer base because they
just can't get their their animals
processed in a timely
manner um and it could open up a whole
other lot of issues if people can't get
their animals processed um also so I
would urge that the committee would to
take a look at this we already have a
Meat Inspection program established dur
in RSA 427 col
um that was established several years
ago and uh for one reason or another
it's never been funded but it's
something that we really need to look at
and also you know that might not be the
answer for New Hampshire but we need to
actually we need to look at seeing how
we
can help farmers in the state and get
food to folks that want Local Foods so I
will entertain any
questions thank you representative did
did you discuss the uh Amendment as
well changes in that I believe well I
read the amendment oh you did okay I'm
sorry
establishing fa in hsh gotcha okay is is
there any uh questions for excuse me for
representative on this representative
Stapleton yeah thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my questions can
you expound a little bit on the reason
or reasons for this uh delay in hooking
up processing USDA slaughterers what's
contributing to this problem um more and
more uh because there's more animals
being processed there's more demand for
local foods and if you want to sell to
the public you have to get a process
through USDA facility now we
have USDA approved facilities but
they're not USDA inspected facilities so
there is a difference and there are a
lot of good me butches so if you're
doing an animal for yourself you can
take it to you don't have to take it to
a USDA facility but if you want to sell
it to the
public you have to take it to a USDA
facility and there's only a certain
number of those in the
state go ahead follow up so um for your
own consumption or maybe you have a
friend or relative and uh that's more or
less like a gift instead of a commercial
sale that would also be free of the USDA
obligation maybe or is that a Gray Line
we shouldn't go there don't go there
okay thank
you any additional
questions Murray did you have a question
I did so um so and just so we're clear
these are two different avenu of lenser
isn't that correct so there is the USDA
and what you're seeking to do is get the
um state inspection facility up and
running so that there would be two
simultaneous avenues for for Farmers to
choose from uh no what I'm this is
proposing is to do a study to see what
the barriers are for New Hampshire Farm
is facing accessing Slaughter facilities
also to look at approaches of improving
availability of Slaughter facilities and
possibly implementing the Meat
Inspection program I it we really need
to do a broad study to see what's best
for New Hampshire I mean it could be
one the other it could be only one but
we don't want to limit ourselves to just
a Meat Inspection program because we
want to do what's best for New Hampshire
and if we just say we're going to study
the Meat Inspection program we're
limiting ourselves uh in the study
committee hey thank you uh
representative Bixby you had your hand
up now it's down did you have a question
uh I did I did but uh representative
comp uh pretty much just covered what I
was going to ask to cover so all right
so I'm good for now I do have a slightly
separate question do you know if Rob
Johnson is going to be testifying he is
on the list yes great
thanks any uh further questions for
representative
contor uh repres Stapleton yes thank you
Mr chair um thank you for taking my
additional
questions
um it addition to the volume in the
market are we also experiencing labor um
skilled labor shortage for this
particular occupation and and um
individual butchers um are they USDA
certified um to
perform um commercial butchering or is
it the slaughterhouse that becomes uh
the USDA qualified
so I'm not sure so if you're a USDA
slaughterhouse or USDA butcher it's it's
all one in the same okay where a butcher
may not be a slaughterer but they would
not be USDA certified because to be USDA
certified your animal actually has to be
brought to the facility where it's going
to be butchered and put down at that
facility right thank you very
much any additional questions
representative Mason yeah I I guess I'm
I'm just old enough to know and been in
the livestock industry long enough um we
used to have state inspection we used to
have state slaughterous inspectors and
and and we we moved away from them uh
the parallel was very close and allowed
us to get our our product over the
market line and sold I I I have to um
concur to what um representative
Stapleton asked is is this more of a
labor issue today to find the people
that are work in those fields and and
and do that and and what would the
difference you know I don't see what the
differences would be that much between
USDA stamp meat and New Hampshire stamp
meat um I do know uh to sell your Meats
um and have any type of insurance for
yourself it needs to come out of a
processed plant that has a USDA stamp on
it um otherwise you can't buy product
liability on from the insurance
companies for this so U we Market myself
we Market lambs and and uh my brother
markets beef and and and we do that
every year and that gets marketed all
USDA um so I'm just I wrestle with it if
it's not a so represent what was your
question my question is you know have
you have you done any research as to
whyatt went away to begin with um thank
you
uh so the answer to your question is no
I haven't really delved into why it went
away um I didn't really realize that we
had one at one point um the other issue
too that we're having with a lot of farm
having with expected me especially when
you're dealing with pork um is that you
can bring it to a USDA house have it uh
slaughtered have a usdaa sticker on it
but if you want bacon
then it creates whole other process
because you can't unwrap that bacon and
then smoke it somewhere else it actually
has to be at a usdaa facility and there
aren't a lot of them around I mean
there's a lot of issues with
um with processing animals that need to
be addressed and I don't know what the
the answers are and that's why I'm
asking for the
study thank you representative any
additional questions
all right seeing none thank you for your
testimony next we will uh bring up Rob
Johnson from the New Hampshire Farm
Bureau thank you Mr chairman can you
hear me you can go ahead
Rob uh thanks again Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Rob Johnson and I represent
the New Hampshire Farm be as a
federation's policy director and we are
supportive
of the amended bill the bill that
broadens the study from not just looking
at the the state state inspection but
also other capacity and inspection
issues and this has been
a a a long uh ongoing longtime issue
back in 2003 uh fine Bureau was part of
a study looking at the slaugh of
capacity and all and and then uh just
with the pandemic hitting last spring it
really brought it to a head with the
closures of the a number of the large
facilities mostly located mostly in the
Midwest and and also with animals that
couldn't be processed out there
especially pigs that were coming here uh
in in uh being purchased and in the
processing needs to give you an idea of
of of the the issue I I saw it uh read a
statistic the other day and I don't
remember it exactly I'll try to find it
but it was just over
80% of all the livestock processed in
this country are processed at its 13 or
facilities just over 80% of 13 or 14
facilities
um representative Stapleton with his one
of his questions he he kind of Hit the
issue and it's why we would ask we're
supportive of the amendment which
expands the study it's it's taking a
look at the workforce issue
that that is that that was a big part of
the the the problem um one of our
facilities in state has told us that
they would hire eight people today if
they could find them we had another
facility that that over this past summer
was down to
employees which which contributed to the
their ability to service their customers
in in the backlog
backlog
um we
we really think the area where we could
make some inroads and where this study
committee would be a particular uh
benefit would be again on that that
looking at the the workforce side of
things and maybe working uh with our uh
uh our uh uh uh Community Technical
Schools and and and such on on the
training that is needed year years ago
oh up until I think the mid 80s uh or
late 80s early 90s right in there UNH
had a meets program and they had a a a a
facility that that where they could
train students and and we no longer have
that they they they sold that off
um I guess just to answer a a couple
other of the questions that came up
representative steton asked the question
about what about uh if you're if the
meat is being processed for your own
consumption well that that would be at a
custom exempt facility like when when
somebody with uh deer hunters that's
where they bring their deer and and that
that that meat can then be given away or
or or used for their personal um
use one thing to to to be aware of is
when it comes to to state Meat
Inspection itself there
are right around 26 27 uh states that
have state programs but that uh that
meat the state St inspected meat must be
equal to or greater than those
inspection programs must be equal to or
greater than the federal program so I
could tell you that the that when we've
talked about this with the commissioner
you know he's pointed that out and and
he's also pointed out that he hasn't
seen the demand he hasn't had anybody
come to him saying I want to open a
state inspected facility because in many
ways it it it it it the why would you
open just a state and Spector facility
and limit yourself to only being able to
process meat that could be sold within
New Hampshire when for really the same
the the the same cost uh you know the um
you you you could open a facility where
your meat could be sold the meat could
go anywhere so there's there's not not
that we're opposed to take a look at our
our the program we have on the books but
uh it's it's questionable whether would
be it's really
useful um and to answer the question
about that yes New Hampshire did have a
a state program that that went off the
books I believe it was 1976 give or take
a year and at the time the the go the
the state decided why why should we have
a program when the federal government
could pay for pay for the same
program
essentially and with with that Mr chair
I'll I'll I'll be happy to answer any
questions all right thank you uh Rob is
there any questions for Rob
representative
Murray I did thank you for taking my
question so I I was hearing you talk a
little bit about the state meet
inspection pro program limiting that
meet solely to the state of New
Hampshire so you're you're seeming to
indicate that potentially the meat like
an online sale type of meat could not
occur with State inspected meat is that
am I inferring that
correctly I I believe so the meat the
meat has to be is the intention of the
statute is it's consumed in in in the
state where the state program is
correct any further questions all right
uh
representative
xby yes uh thank you Mr chair thank you
rob for taking my question um it's
actually more like a request for
information I I think that um a number
of people on the committee might not not
be uh really familiar with the way that
uh the USDA inspection program works and
uh and in and um might not have a sense
of you know how many facilities are
available to New Hampshire farmers at
the moment and if you could just uh and
also the distinction between a USDA
inspected um in um inspected facility
where you have an inspector on site
versus a um
custom facility that is just um where
the facility is certified so if you
could just describe how that system
works uh that might be nice certainly
certainly well that in New Hampshire we
we currently have four federally
inspected facilities those facilities
are located in
Goffstown East
Conway um Center
Barnstead in North havil
and uh State uh excuse
me at a federal inspected facility what
they're in they're inspecting not only
the facility itself but they're
inspecting each
animal that does not happen at what I
refer to as a custom exempt facility
which is basically everything else other
than a a state or federal the at the at
a at a custom exempt facility which we
also have in the State uh the there is
some state and federal oversight but
again they're looking at the facility
not at the animals that's that's the
difference
there in representative Bixby I think
you asked three questions and I've only
answered two uh
I yeah so the
um I I I guess one of the uh I think
something that you mentioned to me
earlier was the uh how the I I I think
you my question what I asked you but
this is sort of a followup um how is the
um the inspector paid for uh that that
would be at a uh USDA inspected facility
and how would that how does that work if
it's a state plan yeah no thank you yeah
that that that's a that's a good point
at a the federal government pays for the
inspectors at a at a federal facility if
if at a with a state program and and Dr
Crawford did a lot of work on on on uh
developing this the state program and
what what he attempted to do there
because the the would be the state would
have to pay and so in putting together
the the New Hampshire program that's on
the books that the the the uh the way it
worked out was that the the user would
would have to pay uh a good part of of
the the in the uh inspector's wage the
the thief to to to pay for the inspector
and and with the the the program that
they that was developed was the using
veterinarians uh to to uh uh inspect uh
animals at at a state facility and as I
understand it one of the the the main uh
issues that USDA had with the the
program was that these inspectors would
not be uh state employees and they had
some concerns that there was not that
oversight at least that was one of their
their uh their
issues okay thank you uh representative
Stapleton uh thank you Mr chair and
thank you again Mr Johnson for taking my
question I'm curious uh your experience
about that uh those training programs at
UNH that were discontinued in the late
80s U how how extensive were they like
an asso degree level or night training
few hours a few weeks what what did it
consist of how long was it yeah my
understanding representative was it was
it was pretty high level it it was it
was it was uh it was basically part of
their a meets program and for for or
students involved in uh livestock uh
courses um but at least it it it it it
gave a a you know
general knowledge is is my understanding
and representative Mason may may be able
to may know a little bit more about that
um but at least it was a it was a start
at least what I'm what I'm I guess is
what I'm getting at and bringing it up
is that there was a facility at the
University that we no longer have and to
bring
something it may be worth the study
committee uh time and effort to look
into that again and maybe it's not at
Una maybe it's somewhere else I I can
tell you within Farm Bureau we've had
discussions with with uh some folks
about uh you know what about there's all
these facilities in state supermarkets
and such and and using those but the the
what you don't what they do at
supermarkets is they're bringing in Box
Beef they're they're not they're not
slaughtering the animal you know live
animal at the rail and and and cut of it
that way so there's a little bit of a
difference but we're again we're trying
to we're EXP exploring using all these
these pieces and parts and I think
that's one of the things we're hoping
that that the uh a study committee could
look at and and actually get the the the
uh educational component whether it's
the community colleges the university
it's all at the table
together thank you for that clarifying
answer thank you representative sakas
did you have a question I did I'm just
curious
about if someone was educated to that
sort of job what um sort of pay
compensation could you see them
having well I'm from what I'm told it's
the pays pay's good it's it's good
um I can't give you numbers but I know
we we over uh recently we've had
discussions one of the one of the
gentlemen that was part of our work
group was was uh worked for hanford's is
a meat cutter and he spent his life with
him and he he said that the pay is very
good thank you it's can I guess to
elaborate a little bit on your question
is you and it's it's a fair one because
if you I guess you're asking well if if
our Slaughter facilities are having
trouble getting workers is that part of
it is the pay a part of it I think more
the issue is it's tough work you're
working in a cool climate year round
it it's it's it's it's it it's only I
guess only certain people are are cut
out to I mean you're killing animals
regularly I mean it it it takes a a
certain individual to do that and
there's some seasonality to the work I'm
look I'm going be a little beyond the
workers here but for the facilities
themselves in in you know in New
Hampshire here I mean livestock are
ready to go to you know um Farmers want
to they don't want to put them feed them
through the winter so they're looking at
the facilities being open you know we're
talking uh uh looking for someplace to
take animals on September October and
through the winter and so that there's
that type of uh of peak but it's it's
it's it's not easy
work okay thank you representative Mason
did you have a
question I do uh thank you for taking my
question um Mr Johnson thank you are you
aware of any protocol difference that
may happen or regulatory differences
that that may appear between a state
program and a federal program that would
ease ease the um process for anybody to
build a less expensive facility or or
dive into this
business
um no no I'm not and and recently one of
our our members who who was on our in
our our LifeStar work group that's
looked at this issue uh he was he was on
a a a couple of webinars with with folks
out in Wisconsin where they do have a
state meet inspection program and they
were saying out there that they found
the federal inspectors easier to deal
with than they did the state inspectors
and and I think we had initially thought
when we first looked at this have been
looking at this that it might be the
other way around because of you know
just the dealing with the the state
bureaucracy versus the federal where
it's a lot closer and you know the
players and and you know they're at a at
a more local level and and least in
Wisconsin they weren't was finding that
to be the
case thank you and I can I can add one
one uh slightly similar thing is uh
recently in the in the uh pandemic pass
uh package that that the uh the
president signed into law uh late late
December just before the new year there
there was a there's monies in that to
provide up to $100,000 grants for Uh
custom exempt facilities to upgrade uh
to to Federal level and USG is currently
working through the rules making process
to determine how they're going to
distribute that but there there's I want
to say was f um something like $50
million uh going towards a $100,000
Grant so it's a good chunk of money and
and that may entice a facility or two a
custom exempt facility or two in New
Hampshire to to uh upgrade
grade as well as potentially some some
facilities in our border states which
our our livestock folks do
use and there's also been efforts uh and
um there are bills in in Congress now
that would uh allow State
inspected uh meat to be sold uh
federally it would go right now you can
only sell interest state within the
state it would allow State inspecting
meets to be sold
uh to in other states how would that
help us in New Hampshire if we don't
have see we don't have state inspected
facilities well like I said our
producers are using facilities in uh
with uh in ver State inspector
facilities in Vermont in Maine and then
if if the meat were if the animals were
brought there then the meat could be
sold
anywhere you Mr Johnson any further
questions all right uh thank you Rob and
I'm sure all of these points that you
brought will be very valuable if the
study committee is uh put into play
because you have a great wealth of
information thank you y you're welcome
is there anyone else would like to
testify on this
bill all right seeing none I'm going to
read the blue sheet we had uh four
people sign in and they were all in
support with that I will close the
hearing on House Bill
437 going to pass the mic off to my vice
chair because the next bill is mine and
we will get underway in about one
minute Mr Mr
chair yes go ahead am I handing the
duties back off to M uh representative
ktoa yes she will take that over M cler
thank you
[Music]
hey good afternoon um I will be
beginning the public hearing for House
Bill
367 uh this is an act relative to Animal
Health certificates and quarantine
requirements for Animals imported into
the state with that I will
yield the mic over to the sponsor of
this
Bill thank you madam chair for the
record my name is Howard
Pearl I live in Lowden and I represent
marac 26 covering the towns of Louden
Canterbury Northfield bosin in ward 3
of I'm here today to introduce House
Bill
367 so this bill is one that we had last
year in in committee and we passed
and we're looking at the same language
again this year
but uh so basically what it would do is
it uh further clarifies in
4378 uh section one that it will add the
name and address of the issuing
veterinarian this is more of a a
housekeeping thing that needs to occur
we felt it would further help identify
the the uh Health the uh yeah the person
that's giving out the health certific
get in and who the animal owner
is the second thing that it does is it
works on the uh
43784 which deals with the quarantine
section for animals that come into the
state that will be
transferred so the concern we had was
that there's many uh different viruses
and and different diseases that won't
manifest and show themselves within 48
hours so that was the concern when we
were looking at this had several
meetings with uh this the state
veterinarian and and the Commissioner of
Agriculture and we talked about exactly
what the right time frame would be
kicked around several different uh dates
as different diseases have different
times that it takes to to
manifest and plus we wanted to look at
uh just further defining that there was
no contact with non- quarantined
animals and that uh animals on the
premises shall receive a uh health
certificate from the licensed
veterinarian before being being offered
for transfer so I have some concerns
that we may not have the exact time
quite right on this yet so we we'll hear
testimony on this but I think in the end
I'm going to ask that the committee will
retain this bill so that we can further
work on it because we are so short on
time this spring in doing our bills and
I I think we need to look a little bit
further on this so with that I'm gonna
I'll open up to any questions from the
committee but I will just tell you we've
got a couple of folks testifying behind
me they have some very good uh
information on this bill and and good
user knowledge within the area so the
technical questions I would ask you to
save for
[Music]
that thank you representative Pearl do I
see any questions from committee yes
representative
k for taking my question thank you
representa um just you mentioned that
you're not sure if you have the timing
the the days right that understanding
and what is concern with that yeah so
we've got seven days in here now there
there are some diseases that take longer
and there are some diseases that would
show quicker and plus the seven days has
been concern raised that this might put
a significant burden on um on some of
the shelters when they were transferring
so I'd like the opportunity to really
look at this and make sure we get it
right before we push it
[Music]
forward any other questions from
committee
members okay seeing
none uh I see that we have a Cody
Gallant who would like to speak on this
bill okay uh we have also to speak on
this bill Stacy
obber good afternoon this is good
afternoon thank you madam chair members
of the committee this is Stacy oer on
behalf of the American Kennel Club I'm
the legislative analyst here in New
England and wanted to express our
support for House Bill
367 and share uh just some background
information with regard to the increased
risk of dogs being imported um into the
country there Americans love their dogs
and there's high demand for dog dogs
that um currently there's higher demand
than dogs available and what AKC has
observed is that more and more there are
rescue organizations that are importing
dogs from outside of the country into
the United States I mentioned earlier
this morning for instance in 2019 dogs
coming from Egypt that had uh rabies and
therefore the CDC issuing a ban on
importing dogs
uh from Egypt for the time being but
basically we've seen in recent years not
only uh that RAB case but also canine
influenza and distemper have been
carried into the US by dogs that are
being imported and um the rescue groups
are sourcing these dogs to shelters uh
in in the United States and some of them
are coming in without basic veterinarian
checks or valid Health certificates so I
wanted to acknowledge that the American
Kennel Club in partnership with um the
American Veterinary Medical Association
has filed last May on the federal level
the Healthy dog importation act which
would look to address this issue um and
to acknowledge that chairman Pearl is
absolutely correct if you look up the
incubation period for instance of some
of the common illnesses that dogs can
carry that are very infectious um it
might vary in terms of a dog showing
clinical signs of for instance canine
parvo virus usually um they will become
ill within six to 10 days after an
exposure and parvo is not unfortunately
an uncommon uh virus that we see dogs
contract especially when being
transported um secondly canine disp
distemper incubation period uh is one to
four weeks and dog infections will take
up to five days prior to any clinical
signs uh being shown um the last one
I'll mention is
leptospirosis which is found in the soil
and natural water sources and it has an
incubation period usually of 5 to 14
days so I wanted just to acknowledge
that uh the sourcing of rescue dogs into
the country from foreign countries that
have very different rules um than the
United States has and we have observed
even uh some fraudulent Health
certificates for instance being used on
bringing some dogs into the United
States which is why we support this bill
and think it would be a wise
move to expand that uh isolation
quarantine period from 48 hours which is
now statute and to and to lengthen
it
okay are there any questions from
committee
members I actually have a
question um so miss obber thank you very
much for coming to testify today um I'm
interested to know you mentioned a
federal law that may be coming or is
being
considered can you see
that yes I'm I I'm wondering if any of
that uh proposed legislation May
conflict with this particular bill that
we're
proposing I don't believe it would uh
the Healthy dog importation Act is
legislation that was filed in Congress
last May and it's been refiled for
consideration this session on the
Federal level in response to some of
these gaps on animals being transported
dogs specifically into the country and
some of them are coming without basic
Veterinary checks or valid Health
certificates um so that Transportation
process in and of itself could expose a
dog to one of these highly contagious
infectious diseases and I don't believe
strengthening the federal law would
minimize the need to still have that
period to observe a dog um prior to
placing it in a new home or a foster
home okay thank you very much for that
um I have representative
Bixby uh would mad ask a question uh
thank you for taking my question Madam
chair thank you uh Miss Ober um I was
wondering if there are um
serological tests that could be done to
detect parvo or distemper or other uh
diseases of concern uh that might make
it make it possible to have a shorter
quarantine
time I would defer to Dr Crawford on
that question I'm not an expert or you
know a veterinarian in terms of having a
background in that area so I don't want
to speak out of turn but thank you for
the question repres resentative I think
it's an important one uh whereas we
heard this morning some testimony noting
that antibody testing for some of these
other infectious canine diseases may
have been approved you know for
determining whether or not the antibody
is is being carried or Not by the
animal okay thank you um representative
Balden you had a question thank you
madam chair and thank you Miss over for
taking my question um in your testimony
you mentioned that dogs are being
imported from other countries um but I
also know that that many people are
buying Dogs online which come from other
states in the US often those dogs are
delivered to a Meetup spot just outside
our state borders by large 18 wheelers
do you know any statistics um on how
many dogs come into our state in this
manner and do we often see these health
issues in these animals
I think you're right it's a growing
concern quite honestly that there's a
circumvention of even the requirement to
isolate and quarantine dogs um some
states have stronger Provisions than
others and it seems that those states
that don't have a solid uh framework in
place
uh states that are adjacent will see
that kind of you know tractor trailer
weekly delivery of dogs uh from out of
state and um a request that anyone
looking to rehome a dog meet in a
parking lot and um I have looked at for
instance uh consumer complaints in the
state of Massachusetts uh from
individuals who have tried to buy a dog
online from out of state or outside of
the country and unfortunately some have
been victim of uh fraud where money was
collected and no dog appeared or if a
dog appeared uh it was very ill uh when
it was received so I I think you're
absolutely right that that is a growing
concern uh representative Balden you
have a followup thank you madam chair
and thank you M over for taking my
followup do you have any concern um that
strengthening or or rather increasing
the um the quarantine period might lead
to more animals coming com in in this
manner and I'm I'm asking that because
my assumption is that the reason they're
coming in that way is because the people
selling those animals want to get around
that 48 hour um
quarantine I I think it really goes to
having the appropriate resources to
enforce the law and and that's where the
focus should be um you know if there is
a channel of communication when
individuals might see that type of
activity and a way to report it to in
New Hampshire the Department of
Agriculture so there can be a followup I
think um it's a matter of having the
requisite resources to ensure everyone's
complying with New Hampshire's
requirements thank you thank you and um
representative um Mason you had a
question thank you madam chair for
taking my question mrar thank you
um yeah as I'm reading this I mean this
applies to state borders so as I read it
it's not just International dogs that
come in but it's dogs coming in from
other states as well is that how you see
this Miss Ober that it would be all all
dogs coming into the state I do and you
know the reason that I reflected on dogs
coming from outside of the state is that
um what comes across my desk is articles
of rescue organizations that are
shipping dogs from out of the country
perhaps into a Southern state and
sourcing those dogs up to shelters that
are in the northeast or the Northwest
where the demand for dogs is quite high
so there's really a um you know a whole
circuit if you will of how to uh get
more dogs bring them into this country
and then move them for placement in the
Northeast where we have a culture of
wanting to adopt and and care for a dog
that's in need of a home
um that sentiment is quite strong here
and um not only are these dogs that
might be Strays for instance down south
some of the southern states have done an
improved job with their spay and neuter
you know uh programs and because of it
some of the rescue groups have begun
transporting dogs from outside of the
country to meet the demand a followup if
I may M Madam CH go ahead
so that would also
apply as this has uh been added that a
person that goes say we a small state
but a person that goes down to a breeder
in
Massachusetts buys a puppy for a stock
dog or purebred dog for himself or 4
project whatever uh comes back into New
Hampshire with that dog as you as you
see this that person would have to give
that dog up for seven days to be held
somewhere to comply with the law no
because that dog would that puppy would
come with a Veterinary record and uh the
the purchaser would have all of the
information around vaccinations and
whatnot and because it was bred locally
and wasn't exposed through some
Transportation channels whether that be
on an airplane coming into the country
and then a holding area for instance
somewhere before being then transported
either by
or um some other vehicle with a large
number of other unrelated dogs to get to
the Final Destination that is typically
where the risk of infectious disease
transmission
occurs thank
you representative hola you had a
question yes thank you uh chair and
thank you for taking my question I'm not
sure if you can if you can answer this
or not but I'm just wondering if the um
adding the days to the do you know if it
there's any unintended consequences that
makes cannibals more vulnerable to you
know any kind of euthanasia concerns
crowding at shelters things like
that I don't have experience managing a
shelter I know last session when this
committee heard this bill there were
individuals that noted they were limited
with space and um felt as though if they
had to is ol at dogs for longer than 48
hours it would reduce the number of dogs
they could accept for transfer and
rehoming okay thank
you are there any other questions from
the committee
members don't see
any so with that I will close this
hearing and uh oh is anybody else want
to testify oh I see some hands up okay
um let's bring Nancy Holmes up
please hello say the unmute work did it
yeah there you are okay great thank you
U I've been listening carefully to the
the testimony and the questions on this
um I'm all in favor of this going
through um even if the time might need
to be increased at some point in the
future I think the protections uh given
over the next year would be um worth
putting it
through um but I think we've all had
pretty much drummed into our brains that
14 days is a good quarantine period
given the last year of of of
covid-19 um the the uh seven days is
however better than 48 hours 48 hours is
just long enough for you to put a sick
animal in a new home that's my feelings
on it um one of the diseases mentioned
is distemper and that can go into
Wildlife too I believe that this bill is
intended only to impact those dogs
brought into the state for transfer not
you're an individual person's um
bringing a dog in for addition to their
home but for dogs that are intended for
transfer um the other thing is that
question about tighter tests was was um
a good one except that one of the things
we did not cover this morning is the
fact you can have a high tighter because
you're sick not just because you've had
a vaccine so a high titer might actually
indicate a dog is ill with a disease and
is trying to fight it off rather than
that a dog is immune to the disease um
so these I think are important things I
understand wanting to get it right but I
think in terms of transition for pet
stores and shelters um or for any
brokers who bring animals in for resale
and into the state I think that going
from 48 hours to seven days and then if
need be upping it to 14 if seven days
isn't sufficient to quell any um
outbreaks that occur in that time period
um I I think it would be easier for
everybody concerned if he started out
with a lower than the optimum number of
days um as far as it being costly for
people um so far as I've seen uh every
business I've seen including shelters
and pet stores the cost is borne by the
purchaser not by the person selling the
animal they may have to initially Pony
up the money but it just goes into what
they charge to get the animal into a new
home um so I think that the cost thing
is is a a temporary issue and would only
really be significant if the animal
never sold um there is some issue with
some types of dogs where the longer
they're held in a shelter
situation um the poorer they do um I
think one of the breeds that's really
well known for that is is the Pitbull
breed they get frustrated and agitated
and more difficult to handle the longer
they are in um a a cage situation but I
don't think that is um normally
considered to be a weak because many
shelters and pounds when they act as
pounds um keep dogs for seven to 10 days
before they are allowed to be adopted
out as a you know from having been a
found or stray animal um so I think
overall the bills of stands is a good
step forward um and in helping make sure
that we don't end up spreading diseases
through our local population of animals
be they domestic or Wild by making sure
that there is time enough to determine
if the animal that's been imported for
sale is going to pass an illness along
um I'd be happy to answer any questions
thank you Miss Holmes is there any
questions for Miss
Holmes seeing
none would like to bring up uh Diane
Richardson hello can can you hear me yes
we can thank you very much thank you for
letting me speak I did I did send you
guys a testimony last night because I
wasn't sure if my connection would be
solid enough to to speak but it seems to
be doing okay so hopefully it'll stick
um I just wanted to bring up a couple
points uh
uh the one of them is that uh in the
news today down in Boston they also have
a 48 hour quarantine they have in the
news they have a couple puppies that
came up to a shelter and they came up
and they ended up having parvo and had
to stay at the shelter for a while so it
it is still coming up with with local
dogs um the the one thing I wanted to do
is to read you my letter from my
veterinarian who wrote this to you guys
last year when this first came out he is
in Claremont New Hampshire there's as
one of the Reps mentioned earlier
there's a big tractor trailer that comes
up regularly and dumps Out quote unquote
rescues from down south to Res to other
rescues and to homes in Springfield
Vermont and he gets a lot of these
puppies in with parvo and other diseases
shortly after they've been adopted um
and it's uh Claremont animal hospital
and the letter is signed by all the Vets
there and it says to whom it may concern
a very nearly Universal recommendation
in veterinary medicine is to isolate new
arrivals from Resident populations of
animals for a minimum of 10 days prior
to exposure of the newly arrived animals
to the resident animals this applies to
all species poultry Bine equine porcine
chamid ovine and
caprine and and he's meaning dogs and
cats as well uh this quarantine allows
time to identify any illnesses or
contagious or infective disease and
usually decreases the potential or
spread of disease throughout a
population this recommendation applies
just as much to dogs and cats brought
from out of state to our area our
practice has seen pets brought in as
quote quote rescues with upper
respiratory diseases parva virus
intestinal diseases scabies demodicosis
and heartworm as well as behavioral
issues we deem a period of quarantining
and assessment by qualified
professionals to be very important in
maintaining the best possible health and
well-being of all
patients uh that's his letter um and I I
think the seven days is bare minimum and
I understand the shelters are are
complaining because right now as the law
states they have to be quarantined at a
veterinary hospital I think we could get
past that by simply saying that they had
to be quarantined at a facility and that
could be a boarding kenel or whatnot I
used to manage a boarding kennel for 11
years and we would we would hold dogs
for rescues for 14 days when they came
in from other out of state before there
was a law that said that um and we were
just A Boarding Kennel we just kept them
in a section where other dogs weren't so
that would be a cost saving method
instead of having to house the animals
in a Veterinary quarantine which is very
expensive and that's it I don't want to
take up too much time thank you Miss
Richardson I just wanted to ask just for
clarification for the record too where
you're calling from and are you
representing yourself or organization
I'm in Springfield New Hampshire and I'm
presenting myself I've been a dog
trainer since the 80s and I managed uh
the very large boarding kennel which was
licensed as an animal shelter for 11
years thank you for that got questions
from
please you also tell
us hi um I am calling from Massachusetts
and I know that I'm not new New
Hampshire um but I I'm about to start
the process of becoming a licensed
rescue in New Hampshire because um our
current operations are in just below the
border so it obvious viously it makes
sense to we are we've been a registered
rescue in the state of Massachusetts for
10 years so we are going to try and
apply for New Hampshire and if this goes
through then obviously it's going to be
you know it's not going to be conducive
to running any sort of operations what I
wanted to point out to any
Representatives who are going to be
voting on this is a couple of things um
you as if you guys don't know there's
always been a battle there's always been
a contentious relationship between the
AKC and rescues always always always all
you have to do is spend five minutes of
your day I'm not going to sit here and
tell you the millions of statistics and
the cases of AKC registered breeders in
the state of New
Hampshire um that have sold unscrupulous
breeders who have sold puppies to
Massachusetts residents that have died
of parvo and because guess who deals
with them I do once their puppy has died
of parvo they decide to go to the rescue
route so breeders are J of have
committed violations and agrees greous
acts just as much as all of the AKC that
is saying that rescuees du as well um
most recently if anybody here knows
anything about Wanda cot who is an
unscrupulous breeder that was AKC
registered in New Hampshire also the W
the great D wolfboro case as well um I'm
just asking representative
please we will not have any uh
disparaging remarks of other people uh
you can State a position but please do
not uh continue with any kind of
disparaging remarks against anyone
else again will Stacy Ober is a
representative of
the okay um I'm going to have to uh end
that um testimony please and um I would
like to
see if there's anybody else any other
questions um seeing
none
um oh Nancy uh you have your hands up
hand up again um so we can bring her up
and just uh briefly because we're
running out of
time I'm sorry can you hear me now yes
okay um I thought that I thought my hand
was down but I I do have have some
something to say uh all we want to do is
make sure that the people have the best
chance of getting a healthy pet because
I'll tell you it really hurts people
when they get an animal that they've
spent all kinds of money on excuse me I
get choked up about this all kinds of
money on and they love it and it dies
within a week or two because nobody who
is bringing it in to sell to them took
the time to make sure absolutely sure
that the animal they were selling was
unhealthy um you know that was healthy
to go to a new home um it you know it's
a Terri it's a terrible thing it's
really hard on like a rescue or a
shelter or even a pet store if one of
the animals they bring in dies but
nowhere near as hard as it is on the
ultimate consumer who loses a family
member out of it and that's all I have
to say thank you he thank you so much
for um for that testimony today Miss
Holmes and uh seeing no other hands up I
will
uh read off the blue seet for uh support
for this bill we had 27 people signed up
in support and 224 people in opposition
to uh HB 367 and with that I would like
to end the um hearing thank you
[Music]
okay we are going to open up the hearing
on uh House Bill
413 looks like we have quite a few folks
signed up to speak I'm going to uh I'm
just going to ask everyone to try to
stick to three minutes because we have
quite a bit of work after this hearing
for the committee to do as well so if we
can keep this reasonable I would uh the
committee would appreciate it uh so I
will bring up the prime sponsor Karen
eel representative Evel my
apologies um good afternoon um chair
Pearl and committee members just making
sure you can hear me we can go ahead
representative thank you great thank you
very much um for the record my name is
uh Karen Eble and I represent marac
District number five which is New London
and Newbury and I'm here to introduce um
hb413 which would establish a solid
waste working group for uh Solid Waste
Management planning and relative to
compost um so
413 uh would create the working group to
be convened by Dees in support of its
Solid Waste planning efforts it would
put a deadline on updating and
promulgation of the state's uh
composting regulations which are long
overdue the bill is the combination of
two virtually identical bills that were
recommended unanimously for p uh passage
by this committee and pass the house on
the consent calendar by Voice vote the
journey was similar in the Senate but
because of covid it got rolled they got
rolled into the Omnibus and
administrative uh Bill uh hb1 1234 and
that was veto by the governor um the
delay in passage is really unfortunate
because those bills uh dealt with issues
of great importance to our state to our
municipalities businesses and citizens
and if you review the co co-sponsor list
you'll see it's a strongly supported by
partisan bill um as you'll recall in
2019 China decided to stop taking solid
waste from the United States where it
had been recycled particularly Plastics
and mixed paper this really put a strain
on our cities and towns and on their
pocketbooks and because of that I
introduced HB
617 and it created a study committee on
solid waste and former representative
John O Conor was on that committee along
with Representatives Megan M Murray and
Senator David Waters and the committee's
goal was to hear from as many
stakeholder groups as possible public
and private landfill operators
municipalities schools
recyclers um state agencies and
nonprofits and what followed uh we were
uh amazed at the interest uh it was a
really active eight-week study we had 14
hearings and over 50 stakeholders
participated so I um gave you uh a link
to the study committee report and if
you're new new to this committee um I
would really commend it to you for your
review because it gives a a quite a good
summary of where we are and the various
Solid Waste challenges that we have and
in my testimony I gave you the link to
the committee web page and there's um
shareholder submissions or stakeholder
submissions minutes and we even had a
continuing education session because
there was so much interest in the talk
IC so one of the things I emailed to you
just to uh kind of highlight the
situation that we're having is a
one-page document that I pulled from our
report and it's uh from Dees and it's
entitled New Hampshire projected waste
disposal need and capacity and if you
look at that now or uh at your
convenience um in uh 2035 for the
current permitting level uh our capacity
really uh
Is Not Great it it just basically
plummets so I think um we clearly have a
problem on our hands and covid we really
were working on this a lot covid stalled
our efforts as it did so many and um we
have a brewing crisis with our landfill
capacity and on top of that we have a
very limited capacity at Dees Solid
Waste Bureau to deal with more than
day-to-day UH responsibilities due to
drastic budget cuts and the problem that
creates is that we have to do Advanced
planning and uh The de's Limited
capacity is really to our detriment and
I just wanted to notice uh note that the
waste management Council which is the
Appellate body for uh the dees Waste
Management division um is also supposed
to help with strategic planning but
given its appell responsibility ities
and the volunteer nature of the board it
has almost no time to do that and um I
believe you do have a letter in support
of this bill from um Mr Rudy basil man
mans from the waste management Council
he's the head of it I was going to read
it into the record for him but since uh
you're tight on time I you have it so um
I'll just leave it there I'm I was um
and I would say that our idea is to
include a member of the Waste Management
Council on this task
force so the recycling study committee
made many recommendations but two of the
most important was the creation of this
um task force to help
Dees and the other uh aspect of it uh is
to um put a deadline on the promulgation
of the uh
compost uh regulations that Dees is
supposed to uh bring forth Ward so with
a long-term Solid Waste planning in the
offing uh Dees really needs assistance
with input and problem solving and I
just want to be plain here that de's
Solid Waste Bureau is generally funded
it used to have a planning division but
because of consistent Bud budget cuts
now it doesn't and we have not had a
longrange solid waste plan which is
supposed to be produced every six years
since 2003 and we desperately need need
one other states are working very hard
on this in some cases they're
instituting specific solid
waistbands and in some cases where refu
is banned in one state we are the
recipients in our landfills and
Massachusetts and Vermon are two
examples because of the interstate
commerce clause we cannot ban outof
State
wastes um so one obvious way to decrease
uh the amount amount of waste going into
our landfills and help with our capacity
is to try to limit the amount of food
waste it contributes up to 20% of the
solid waste in weight and it should be
composted to the extent possible the
study committee uh we on the hearing
that we had on composting we had a very
large turnout and I would say it was the
thing that was of most interest to um to
the well to the committee because we had
such a such a turnout and part of it was
the regul regulatory structure just
really needs to be updated and Dees has
struggled to get this done even though
it was tasked to do it um originally
starting their work was supposed to
start in 2015 and it still hasn't gotten
done um I believe it can help uh spur a
new business and um we really need to do
it it'll save municipalities money and
um
by putting a deadline in here and I've
spoken to Dees you know with their
prioritization and everything they
should be able to get this done and I
think it it does need to um to happen so
just um that basically concludes my
testimony I did also send to the
committee a suggested Amendment um and
that is amendment 2021 hyphen
0343 and and uh the upshot of that
Amendment as I explained in my cover
note to you um just to provide for some
continuity in the in the membership all
this does is i' because I've seen it on
different boards that I've served on
it's very helpful uh an appointed member
just serves until they're replaced um
and that gives some continuity to the
body so that's the first section of the
amendment but really more importantly um
in talking with uh Dees the deadlines
that were in the original Bill really
didn't give Dees an opportunity to do
anything meaningful they were just so
tight so um I moved out the
organizational meeting to occur no later
than November 1st 2021 instead of 60
days after um after the bill uh passage
should it pass and then I'm moved out
the date of the initial um reporting
requirement to
2022 because I mean it's just it was It
was kind of ridiculous to ask them to do
a report maybe two months after they uh
originally convened and this will
provide some much more meaningful um
input opportunity for the task force and
I made it a five-year task force so
that's what and it automatically uh
would repeal November 1st 2026 so that's
what the amendment
provides and just in conclusion I just
wanted to say Dees does a fantastic job
it has ever dwindling
resources and um it was really important
one of the top recommendations by our
recycling committee that we put together
a working group to uh bolster de de's
planning capacity to facilitate its
stakeholder um
participation and also uh if we just get
these composting regulations done it
should create more business and cost
savings I urge passage of this important
bill and I'm happy to ask any questions
answer any questions
sorry thank you representative I guess
you can ask us too I wouldn't dream of
it all right uh representative South AAS
has a question for you sure hi um
representative AEL um nice to hear from
you again I um I'm just curious about
this interstate commerce clause um is
there a ratio of how much outof State
garbage we have to accept um because
we're a very small state and next to Big
States so I'm just wondering about who
decides how much garbage comes in well
um I'm I can answer in in summary but
the person who really knows the answer
the best to that question is um Mike nor
who I believe is here to testify from
Dees but the short answer is that we
cannot ban outof State West uh waste
under the um interstate commerce clause
however as part of the permitting
process the dees looks at our needs and
um sort of assesses what the amount of
capacity that needs to be reserved for
our state um under certain circumstances
and he can give you more detail um what
I also wanted to say in addition to the
interstate commerce clause from a
capacity
standpoint um local control local
regulations um also have an influence on
permitting so on the creation or
expansion of a new landfill
you really also have to get the approval
of the uh local Town
boards thank you thank you
representative uh
representative hello
sorry hello had your hand raised did you
have a question I did sorry did you
call I'm who did you call on
representative
D okay thank you sorry it kind of broke
up um thank you for taking my question
thank you chairman Pearl um
representative eel uh in New Hampshire I
think it's well known that a lot of work
is done by volunteers and that the uh
state government depends on volunteers
to do this work and it seems to me like
your bill is promoting that once again
that instead of having professionals who
are paid in the department uh now we
will have a group of volunteers who will
be doing this work did your Comm uh when
you were drafting this bill did you give
any consideration uh to looking at how
the state might go ahead and increase
the funding or develop accounts that may
be used uh by Dees uh for uh forward
planning um well in the recycling
committee study report one of the
recommendations um in addition to just
highlighting how desperately under
funded the uh Bureau is was that we
investigate um adding an additional
dollar to the per ton tipping fees and
then setting up a grant program that
could be utilized um by folks who wanted
to develop uh a murf or other
methodologies uh to help with uh Solid
Waste Management it also um the bill
well that was the recommendation
actually there was a bill that came out
of it that was tabled due to covid um
the other aspect of the bill that was
proposed and what was recommended by the
committee was that um tipping fees that
were uh paid by
municipalities those funds would be um
returned so we did look at that
particular method of um of developing
more fun fing and in the study committee
report you'll see that
virtually I mean at the time the study
was did done uh on tipping fees I think
something like three quarters of the
states in the United States uh have a
tipping uh fee added to the regular
tipping costs that help uh fund State
efforts for planning thank
you thank you uh representative Kaplan
yes thank you Mr chair for taking my
question uh thank you Miss e
representative eel for uh the great work
you've done and to the uh members of the
previous study group for all the all the
excellent work on this issue which is so
important um I just had a question about
some of the deadlines for issuing uh
regulations or recommendations that
would come out of this
bill um there's an
interim there's an interim report that
is supposed to come out uh I guess in
2021 November 2021 would that include
the uh composting
regulations well so um no it wouldn't
include the composting regulations
because the composting regulations are
supposed to be done by September I think
it was 30th of
2021 um and the amendment that I
proposed to the committee was that we
have the interim report be um required
to be delivered November 3rd 30th
2022 and part of the reason there and
again Mr nor could talk some more about
it but in talking to the
department um the actually they're
trying to get the long-term Solid Waste
plan done um and it's due by October
2022 and so the thought there is that
the task force would be working with the
Department as it develops that Solid
Waste plan and its first report which
would be due November whatever 30th 2022
would append the uh Solid Waste
plan okay thank you I have a followup
question if I may Mr chair sure go ahead
this is on just a totally unrelated uh
issue but uh and we might hear some more
of this from other people testifying
later but would you consider adding a
position on the commission uh to members
of uh citizens groups or uh other public
interest groups that might have a stake
in this issue and have been working on
this issue I mean I'm I'm open to what
the committee might want to do um you
know I I tried to look at all the
different stakeholder groups that
participated I kept in mind how big the
task force was I gave uh Dees some
latitude if they wanted to add to it but
even if they did add to it I am quite
sure knowing them that in the Outreach
that they did to stakeholders they'd be
sure to get um representation from a
variety of groups including the group
you
mentioned thank
you okay uh thank you uh representative
Bixby yes thank you uh Mr chair for uh
taking my question thank you
representative eel um I just uh
a question getting back to the um the
bill that would have created a sear
charge on the Tipping fees do you know
if uh a similar bill has been rein uh
has been um submitted again for this
year uh Senator Waters introduced that
bill last year uh he did not reintroduce
it to my knowledge okay thank you but he
did just to I'm sorry I'm sorry go ahead
representative Bixby just just a a quick
note on the um the timeline for the
composting the legislation that required
that composting was actually passed in
2015 right I mentioned yeah yeah and so
I mean I know that the uh Department had
a task force that it was working with
but again because they are just
unbelievably strained within the
department it's made it extremely
difficult for them to um to get them
done but you know through the study
committee process and by putting this
deadline on and I mean I I think they
feel that they're going to be able to
accomplish at this time and it's
incredibly important for maintaining our
capacity Business Development and people
just really want to get it done I think
it would be a great thing to put the
deadline on and move
ahead if you if you didn't mind Mr chair
I just wanted to add on the question of
the search charges there there is
another bill that's pending in the sen
that was vetoed at the same time same
time that my other two bills were and
that was to um reduce the solid waste
reduction goal because there's a goal in
149 M That was supposed to be achieved I
don't know if it was the year 2000 or
what but it's just it really the whole
thing needs to be updated and if that
passes the Senate which it did before um
you'll be getting that thank you for the
heads up
uh representative Aaron has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative EO for all the work that
You' done
on working group study
and as
well my question
is will
any is the working group going to be
touching on any
I'm sorry that's cutting out did you say
sighting do you mean like landfill
sighting talk about uh land sighting at
all well I think you
know I'm looking at the recommendations
here and um you know they're looking at
Solid Waste Disposal landfill capacity I
just can't imagine that in the realm of
uh looking at capacity
that they wouldn't also be talking about
citing challenges um I mean let's face
it it it's huge and if our current
landfills are tapping out um we've got
to figure something out I I really I
feel like I should mention here too
which I did in my cover note you know we
have in our Solid Waste reduction um
statute a
hierarchy of what we're supposed to do
to try to um manage our goals and that
the top of the hierarchy is Source
reduction and then it goes to recycling
and reuse composting waste to energy
technology um incineration without
resource recovery and at the very very
bottom is landfilling and of course
unfortunately I think most of our Solid
Waste is ending up in the landfill and
um you know we need to harness uh the
things that are going into a landfill
through Recycling and and reuse and we
really need to reduce our um our source
sources and I I mean I would just say
one of the reasons on the study on the
study committee or the task force I put
somebody in there that that actually
uses Goods to reprocess and produce
other Goods as something to that so that
we can have them in there
talking thank you for that thank you
representative
all right uh I don't see any hands
raised so I appreciate your testimony
you did a wonderful job highlighting the
bill and we certainly appreciate all the
work that you've done on this and and
the issue previously thank
you all right I'll remind everybody
we've got eight more folks that would
like to speak so if we can try to keep
it to around three minutes and not
repeat what uh other testimony has
already been previously done would be
great I'll call Representative Megan
Murray next
there honorable colleagues I'm going to
keep this extremely short because much
was said before me but um you all have
received my testimony and one of the
things that I just wanted to in
particular highlight was that we really
do have um with with with specificity to
compostable food waste um we really have
an opportunity to get that heavy food um
food waste out of landfill streams and
divert it into compostable into a
compostable solution rather than its
heavy Mass being hauled at municipality
expense and encapsulated um forever in
landfills and um I just again as you as
you heard the complex nature of um solid
waste and recycling in New Hampshire if
we are going to adapt and continue to be
a forward-thinking um Community where we
seek to grow and change uh we also have
to make sure that we're addressing this
need and it it is urgent at this point
thank you
thank you representative that was brief
I appreciate it any questions for
representative
Murray all right not seeing any thank
you I will call uh representative
Suzanne
Smith thank you Mr chair and U members
of the committee for the record I'm
Suzanne Smith I represent the towns of
Plymouth Hein and Holden Grafton County
District 8 I will be brief also as
representative eel did such an excellent
job um but even back when I was serving
on the environment and agriculture
committee 12 years ago Solid Waste was a
big issue and composting was a big issue
and the EPA estimates that 63.1 million
tons of food waste was generated by
commercial institutional and residential
sectors in 20
8 21% of the total solid waste of
municipalities and if we compost more of
our food waste it will be a giant step
towards reducing the bulk in landfills
as well as contributing to healthy soils
and and that are so important for
agriculture so um I'm not going to say
much more but uh composting is near and
dear to my heart um both for what it
does to the soil and what it keeps out
of the landfill and so I ask for your
support on House Bill
413 and thank you very much thank you
representative any any questions for
representative
Smith all right see n we thank you for
your
testimony uh next we'll pull up uh
Michael Nor from
Dees good afternoon uh chairman Pearl
members of the committee thanks for the
opportunity U for the record my name is
Michael Nor I'm providing testimony on
behalf of the solid waste management
Bureau at
Dees and in short Dees supports this
bill and the amendment that was
recommended by uh representative eel um
as was discussed at length by
representative eel I won't rehash her
discussion but the solid waste and
recycling study committee back in 2019
Unearthed good deal of uh information
there's lots of resources on their
website
um and you know there's definitely a
need for the state to take a more
proactive role in Long Range Solid Waste
Management planning and addressing the
the Myriad Solid Waste issues that face
our state and the region and pursuant to
149 M um Dees is the the agency
responsible for solid waste planning and
we are required to periodically update
the state Solid Waste Management plan
however over the last 20 years or so um
the department has had severe resource
deficiencies which has made it difficult
for us to uh fulfill you know the solid
waste management plan mandate as well as
other duties that have gone unmet for a
number of years and that's not to say
that they aren't important or priorities
for us it's just that we have been
challenged to be able to address them um
and I also want to note that this bill
in developing a uh Solid Waste uh
stakeholder workg group um would be an
important tool and helping us to um you
know start addressing some of those
issues and to you know Advance a
conversation about updating the solid
waste management plan and uh looking at
other innovative ways that we can
address Solid Waste challenges however
this bill would not address our resource
deficiencies in itself um
and I do want to note that other states
commonly engage so the state agencies
that are overseeing solid waste
management in other states they also
commonly engage with stakeholder work
groups um and advisory groups to help
guide policy and development and uh you
know identifying priorities for Action
um so this would be something that would
you know help us
to you know keep in line with that kind
of effort um the solid waste and
recycling study committee in their
report noted that New Hampshire is
falling far behind in terms of you know
long-term planning and those kinds of
activities so this this working group
would be a help in that in that regard
um and I just also want to note that
with regard to composting rules and
Adoption of revised administrative rules
um as was noted there was the
sb251 uh back in 2015 which directed
Dees to uh basically clarify
requirements for composting of uh meat
and dairy food waste uh in 2017 and 2018
the department held u a series of
stakeholder workg group meetings uh to
help inform us on making those revisions
regrettably however we have not been
able to uh you know carry carry through
on actually adopting revised regulations
to date again because we've been uh you
know deficient in terms of our uh
resources to to have dedicated resources
to do that work um but you know this is
something that is definitely a priority
um you know we continue to to work on it
and to advance that that project um and
should HB 413 be an acted into law um
you know we would do everything within
our power to be able to meet this
September 30th deadline to enact those
administrative rules so in summary um we
support uh moving forward on stakeholder
workg group and we also support u a
deadline for September 30th of
administrative rules for composting
facilities with that I'll stop my
comments but if you have any questions
for me I might be able to address I'm
happy to to take
them thank you Mr NK any questions uh
representative Bixby yes uh thank you Mr
chair thank you Mr NK for taking my
question I was just wondering how many
people uh that you have in the solid
waste
division uh currently we
have I believe seven full-time seven or
eight full-time
staff that is down from it's less than
half of what it used to
be okay thank
you all right any other questions for Mr
[Music]
Nork seeing none we thank you for your
testimony thank you uh next we have John
Swan from safe for us late he's not
on Mr Swan if you're on could you put
your hand up so we can find
you we have a John Tut Hill is that uh
is that the same as Mr John
Swan okay then we'll we'll hold off on
Mr T Hill um next we have Mark Morgan
from the city of
Lebanon oh Mr Morgan all right we will
move to Reagan biset from the national
resource recovery
Association thank you chairman Pearl and
members of the
committee my name is Reagan Binet I'm
the executive director of the Northeast
resource recovery Association
and we were closely involved with the
study committee that representative eel
LED in the fall of
2019 the Northeast resource recovery
Association is a recycling nonprofit and
we have worked with municipalities
throughout New Hampshire to help them
increase their Recycling and reduce
their waste for the past 40 years and
about 80% of New Hampshire
municipalities are members of our
organization we do not take a position
on
hb413 but rather I wanted to share some
testimony um regarding our
municipality's experience with Recycling
and composting as it relates to this
bill and as written hb413 would include
one representative from the Northeast
resource recovery Association as a
member of the solid waste working group
and we would welcome the opportunity to
participate
I as you've heard from several people
improved Solid Waste planning in New
Hampshire especially for recycling and
composting would help
municipalities save money and conserve
natural
resources the Northeast has the highest
cost of disposal of solid waste compared
to the entire country and we expect that
that cost of landfilling material will
only increase over time which will make
finding other ways to reduce waste more
valuable and um financially important
for
municipalities in particular if we are
able as a state to update our food scrap
composting regulations to address the
composting of meat and dairy that would
likewise help municipalities save money
as well as conserve environmental
resources um you heard from
representative eel about the large L
amount of food that is landfilled in the
United States actually the most recent
information from the Environmental
Protection Agency from
2018 shows that food waste accounts for
24% of all the waste by weight that we
are disposing uh in landfills as a
country and landfilling food scraps is
very expensive because food scraps are
heavy and communities have to pay by
weight to dispose of their trash now the
delay in modernizing our composting
rules in New
Hampshire is been problematic for
municipalities because many of our
Municipal members have expressed an
interest in having food scrap composting
programs but relatively few have done so
to date and that is because asking
residents to take the cumbersome
additional step of separating out meat
and dairy from their other food scraps
before composting those is a real
limitation on the ability for us to have
widespread Municipal and commercial food
composting in New Hampshire um so for
example the town of Hollis has a food
scrap composting pilot program um but it
does not include meat and dairy I know
that um Mark Morgan from Lebanon they
are one of the very few municipalities I
believe perhaps the only municipality in
the state that is composting food scraps
including and dairy and that's because
they went through a special uh process
with New Hampshire Dees to enable that
and the other thing I just want to add
is that the delay in Ru making for
updating our composting regulations is
also discouraging composting businesses
from establishing themselves in New
Hampshire so for example Mr Fox
composting which some of you may know
serves a number of municipalities in the
Sea Coast they are able to pick up food
waste from New Hampshire and then they
take it to their facility in Maine and
uh reportedly they're they chose to
locate in Maine rather than New
Hampshire because Maine's composting
regulations were more favorable to their
business model so I I do see
that updating our composting regulations
would both benefit our municipalities
and would also benefit um you know
business options and opportunities in
the state of New Hampshire
and thank you and I am happy to answer
any questions you may have very much are
there any questions from
isbet I represent hola thank you chair
and thank you for taking my question can
you tell me what is what's the afterlife
of composting what is done with the
composted
material sure so the the ideal use for
composted material is that it would get
used as uh a soil amendment for Gardens
for
farms for growing new um for growing new
plants some compost material is also
used as what's called alternate daily
cover for landfills landfill active
landfills have a requirement to cover up
the active portions of their landfills
on a daily basis and uh I believe if
Mark Morgan was available to join us
today I'm fairly confident that that's
actually what they're doing with their
compost in uh the city of Lebanon but
the most common is to use it as h a soil
amendment sure follow go ahead thank you
and um when uh companies uh make this
their their business are they supplying
to these landfills are they supplying to
Farms um can you do you have any
information on
that I think it varies I I think that
they'll look for whatever profitable
Outlets they can find for their material
so the the highest and best use would be
to use composted material for uh for
farms and for gardening um a you know a
lesser beneficial use would be to use it
as landfill cover so I I think that it
it varies by company thank
you any other
questions all right seeing them thank
you for your testimony
thank you next we have uh Haley Jones
from the community action works
campaigns Haley if you're there raise
your hand so we can find
you all right seeing none we will move
to uh Henry vou from the Waste
Management Incorporated
hi uh thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee uh for the record my
name is Henry veu and I'm here on behalf
of Waste Management uh Waste Management
the company not the division of Waste
Management over at Dees um uh Waste
Management uh has the state's largest uh
landfill in
Rochester um we
recently um got a prmit uh for the
expansion which will
extend the life uh of the landfill till
2034 uh so in Hampshire communities will
have a place at least at
Rochester um till 2024 to dispose of H
Solid Waste uh we're also in the
recycling business uh we have a
materials uh recovery facility in b r
Mass um so a lot of New Hampshire's
recyclable materials uh and up in Bel R
um here today just toh support uh the
legislation we worked with the
representative eel and representative
former representative Connor um uh
through the last uh task force that met
uh which produced this bill before you
today um and we would be happy to work
um as a member of the uh working group
that this uh legislation would establish
and we answer any
questions thank you any questions from
Mr
R seeing none I think we're good thank
you for your
testimony okay that's all I have on my
list so is there anyone else that would
like to
testify all right Mr John Tut Hill
there we go
hello could you please tell us where
you're from and who you representing
yeah my name is John Tut Hill I live in
aworth New Hampshire former member of
the environment and agriculture
committee we're dealing with solid waste
back then as well 20 years ago um
I just I I'm in support of this bill
obviously planning is long overdue I
would support the suggestion that
perhaps we broaden a little bit uh the
perspective of some of the
participants as we continue to hear a
year after year about the landfill
capacity crisis I think it's pretty
clear what we have got is a
u a capacity to plan is is more of our
problem than the actual
landfills um we have continued to Kick
the Can down Road year after year decade
after decade and I think that's why we
find ourselves in the situation we're in
uh I was surprised to hear uh from
representative AEL that there is a bill
in the Senate this year proposing to
reduce uh the state's reduction goals
which are about 20 years old um we
should in fact at this point be looking
at increasing our reduction goals uh an
appeal before the waste management
Council uh last year I believe uh made
it quite clear that the problem isn't
the goal so much it is a dispute over
how do you account for reduction and
this is a problem of not having obtained
adquate data over the years in terms of
what is being diverted what is being
recovered what is being recycled and
what is being
disposed
um there are a couple of myths the first
is the landfill capacity crisis uh which
is a manufactured crisis and essentially
a failure I think on the part not of
Dees uh but over the years failure on
the part of the legislature to develop
responsible policies for
reducing uh the amount of waste needing
to be gen uh disposed of in the state
much of which at this point because we
are in a privatized system is coming in
over uh over the state borders uh that
gets us to the second myth which has to
do with the international Commerce
Clause on the face of it is quite true
that it is not possible to regulate a
commodity like waste um however there
are many ways to uh more responsibly and
effectively
um control of the materials that are
coming into the state and how they will
be uh managed and disposal is as we know
through the hierarchy the least
preferred method the two disposal
options being waste incineration with
and without energy recovery and
landfills uh Vermont has done a very
good job I think of limiting the amount
of importation into the state Maine has
got the mechanisms for doing doing it
but for whatever reason has chosen not
to Avail itself of those mechanisms but
that is certainly something that the
state of New Hampshire and this uh
working group should be looking at uh
that is part of management so I really
in closing would just like to emphasize
that
um focusing on zero waste planning I
think is the key going forward we're in
the 21st century now this is common
around the world um even looking within
the Northeast but beyond the Northeast
and other States and in other countries
uh we we really are still running a very
archaic system here um relying very
heavily on disposal so I'll wrap up
there I know your time is limited and
you've got bills to exec but I I really
think we need to just you know step back
really take the time to get this right
and not continue to use the same outm
outmoded models um which are far too
reliant on disposal Tech Technologies
thank you thank you Mr taill any
questions from Mr
taill all right seeing none thank you
appreciate your
testimony oh we have Mr Morgan now has
his hand raised so I'll go back to him
Mark
Morgan
from go ahead Mr Mor okay I'm sorry the
the unmute settings are a little
different on this thank you for H for
your time um I'm the solid waste manager
for the city of Lebanon and um I've been
working in the waste and recycling
industry in New Hampshire for several
decades um and during my career I worked
for New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services for a group
called the uh Solid Waste planning and
community assistance group um our
primary task was to do Solid Waste
planning uh that group has not been EX
in existence for a number of years and
as a result uh the state of New
Hampshire is not doing Solid Waste
planning um I firmly appreciate
everybody's uh comments about increasing
recycling the unfortunate thing is that
the majority of New Hampshire's
landfills are managed by private
entities where if we increase recycling
it'll it's not going to impact the
overall disposal at those landfills I'm
not saying that recycling is not a good
thing it absolutely should be part of
the equation however without fully
understanding the the state of the
Hampshire's uh position in the waste
industry as well as how we um figure
into the Region's waste disposal needs
for instance in the past decade the
state of Massachusetts has issued
disposal bands they've also issued
moratoriums on landfill expansions as a
result waste from Massachusetts is
pouring into the state of New Hampshire
just because it's um it's an easier flow
for Waste uh than going into
Massachusetts so we did not prepare for
that those regulatory changes in our
neighboring states um because we don't
have a group that looks at that uh Dees
does an excellent job at at doing what
they do and focusing on statutory
obligations but planning is a critical
piece in um managing New Hampshire's
future disposal needs simply looking at
permits and determining their
eligibility and correctness for um you
know rules um is not planning um looking
at what we need the future growth of
this state and what our hopes and Desir
are um is not accomplished by issuing
permits alone I I can't emphasize the
need for solid waste planning in the
state of New Hampshire um it does not
generate Revenue but It prepares um our
residents businesses and institutions
for a more secure future both
environmentally fiscally and uh and
socially so those are my comments um in
regards to this bill I couldn't support
it more I My Hope is that um you know
that the state would see more value in
in looking to the Future um in and
looking more broadly at this at this
issue thank you Mr Morgan any questions
from Mr
Morgan I one representative Stapleton uh
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
Morgan that is quite disturbing um that
bans of certain materials waste in
Massachusetts forces the move to fill
our landfills here in New Hampshire do
we have any type of bands of such
materials to limit that sort of uh
transfer um I'm I'm not aware of
anything New Hampshire does have its own
waste bands but one um example of just
massachusetts's impact on New Hampshire
is in Massachusetts you can't landfill
unprocessed construction and demolition
debris so what that means is you tear
down a house in
Massachusetts that waste from a house
tear down has to be sorted and ground up
um before it can make its way into a
landfill that's not required in New
Hampshire so the cost of that activity
um is expensive and from a business
standpoint it's easier to move that
waste into New Hampshire where we're
managing construction and demolition
debris already but unprocessed
construction and demolition debris
consumes a disproportionate amount of
space in a landfill and by that what I
mean is you know a ton of construction
demolition debris consumes an far more
airspace in a landfill than a ton of
Municipal Solid Waste or or processed
construction and demolition
[Music]
debris follow up uh one follow yep so um
we we need to be looking at uh some
regulation or statute to uh protect our
landfill capacity by U similar bands do
we
not um again I think that's part of
planning and before we just start doing
um forgive me sir knee-jerk reactions
with statutory responses to neighboring
states um legislative activities we need
to understand what they're doing um a
lot of waste in Mass Massachusetts is
moving to uh the Midwest right now um by
rail so it's actually being transported
far distances um out of our region but
um we need to understand exactly what um
what n Hampshire is doing what our
forecast looks like before we start
making um I mean I appreciate and
applaud your desire to
um to ban certain waste the city of
Lebanon has done that locally we passed
an ordinance Banning the disposal in in
our landfill of unprocessed construction
and demolition debris as a method to uh
manage uh you know reduced landfill
disposal um landfills fill up by Nature
uh and we need to be looking at them you
know as as literal spaces that um that
will go away and at some point in our
children's future
they will be faced with having to make
disposal decisions that we are not even
considering right
now thank you very much thank you any
other
questions all right seeing none thank
you we appreciate your testimony thank
you sir all right we got two more folks
with their hands up I'm gonna ask that
you guys keep it really brief because
we're running very long here so uh
Kristen
Cummings if you could unmute and tell us
where you're from and who
representing good afternoon chairman
Pearl and members of the committee um
thank you for the opportunity to submit
comments on this bill and my name is
Kristen Cummings and I'm a resident at
hopkington um I just like to voice
enthusiastic support for um House Bill
413 to move forward um there's several
Provisions in it that would help the
town of hopkington with our Solid Waste
Management challenges over the past six
years um we share a transport station
with uh with with Webster and Hopkinson
um we've experienced a disproportionate
incre increase in the amount of waste
coming to our transfer station um while
our population Rose by only about 2%
from 2013 to 2019 our total waste tonage
stored by nearly 12% we're currently
producing over 3,000 tons of mssw mix
Solid Waste annually um not including
the additional tonnage of other waste
like construction um and de demolition
debris Tire shingles the like um
undoubtedly Co has had some impact on
this growth in disposable waste but the
onset of the trend predated the P the
pandemic um we really don't fully
understand why our waste has increased
um to its current level but the trend is
super concerning um concurrent to the
increase in solid waste volume our
ability to cover the cost of disposal
has diminished as of January 1 of this
year we entered into into a new
five-year contract with Waste Management
to transport and dispose of our mixed
Solid Waste and our our price increased
by almost $10 a ton um in 2021 and will
continue to increase incrementally by
contract through
2025 um Meanwhile we're really
struggling with low participation in our
pay as you throw bag program um it's
been in effect since 2010 and it
was our disposal
costs are you reading the testimony that
you sent to us as a committee oh yes I
was I I thought I was supposed to submit
it written as well is that not correct
no man we we're running really late so
perhaps if you could just wrap up with a
quick summary in the next 30 seconds
sure um in summary I enthusiastically
support passage um of this bill and um I
thank you all for your time and your
continued work on Solid Waste Management
thank you very much I appreciate that
all right we have one more uh Katie
leoy if you could unmute and tell us uh
where you're calling or where you're
testifying from and who you're
representing
hello can you hear me yes we got you now
go
ahead oh good thank you um yes I'm uh
representing working on waste where a
longstanding Citizens uh initiative that
promotes safe alternatives to waste in
generation we support this bill with the
following
recommendations um we want we the
working group will focus on managing
resources not waste we've we have worked
to raise awareness about zero waste
initiatives uh that Mr Tuttle referenced
earlier and um the underlying pres
premise is that waste is a behavior it's
something we do collectively and as
individuals and policy changes can incen
Vis less wasteful Behavior the working
group will include members of the public
who advocate for public health in the
environment and the working group will
also include broader representation from
organizations with the same Mission and
the working group will accept and
address oral and written input from
interested parties who are not members
those are our
recommendations we also included in an
email to you this morning uh a letter uh
sent to Representatives eel Murray or
Conor or Conor and Senator Waters in
2019 um and this letter uh was part of
Representative eel's committee and it
will help set priorities for your
working group um and thank you very much
for the opportunity to speak with you
today thank you very much we appreciate
your
testimony all right with that I'm going
to uh wrap up this hearing and read the
blue sheet we have 85 members in support
one in opposition and two that are
neutral so we thank everyone for their
testimony I think we're going to take
about a five minute break and give the
committee a chance to stretch their legs
and use the facilities if they need to
and then we'll rejourn at 3:05 and start
our exec session
I just want to mention one thing I
learned from watching our committee
meetings on YouTube is
that
for
e
e e
Mr chair I just want to let you know
that I did mute the um the room if you
could unmute before you
start e
okay we're going to come back in and
start our exact session with House Bill
272 this is uh act relative to the
labeling and sale of hemp products
containing
CBD and I will be looking to
representative Duty for a
motion thank you Mr chairman uh I would
like to move house Bill
272 and offer Amendment
202-
045h for a vote of otpa ought to pass
with Amendment and I would like to speak
to both the bill and the
amendment okay uh I have a move a motion
for OTP with an offering Amendment uh
2021 045h D have a second second
representative steton is second I will
recognize representative duty to speak
to her motion thank you um this bill is
before us because the federal government
which normally controls product labeling
hasn't acted uh we had a public hearing
on this bill uh I think approximately
two or three weeks ago there were a
number of suggestions made by the public
at that time and representative kerk who
is also on the call uh and I have been
working to incorporate all of those
suggestions into the bill so basically
what you have with the amendment uh is a
replacement of the bill and I believe
all of you have received uh some
correspondents from representative kerk
that outlines uh the changes that were
made but in in summary it was suggested
that instead of uh having the HHS do the
uh inspection uh of Laboratories that we
go with Laboratories that our ISO
certified and that was placed in the
bill um so that uh it lessens the amount
of work that HHS has to do uh there was
also um a suggestion that we add an
expiration date as to one of the things
that would be on the label and the main
thing that um committee members I
believe were concerned with uh was how
the implementation of this bill uh was
going to be paid for and we came up with
the idea of creating a canaba pro uh uh
program fund that we are looking to
Industry um to help fund along with
registration
fees uh so regarding the registration
fee you'll see in the amendment that
we've um decided on
$250 for a registration fee per product
and a product would be considered a
formulation um not determined by size so
if the product had the same formulation
but it was offered in various uh sizes
that would be considered one
registration um we talked to industry
leaders uh in this area and we got
registration prices all the way from
$50 would be adequate to up to
$500 uh so it was all over the uh all
over the map and and we felt that
$250 per product uh would be
reasonable um we also I also have a
letter that I sent out to you from the
uh NPA the natural products Association
uh they're the first to come on board
and uh will be committing funds uh to
the cannibal dial program fund uh we've
reached out to other industry uh
resources also have not heard back but
this is something that we would want to
continue to um to work on um so with
that um I'll take any questions that you
might have and if I can't answer them uh
I believe representative kerk would be
able to
thank you representative uh is there any
other comments I see representative
Aaron has her hand up yes thank you and
thank you so much for your work on this
representative I just wanted to clarify
uh what what we had uh come to terms
with with regard to uh sales coming from
the
internet for maybe businesses that are
are
Hampshire out ofate
or I I think rep Bixby is actually going
to comment on that so why don't we uh
why don't we let him answer that right
so um the uh the bill as amended has the
phrase uh that basically defines a uh
kabad a CBD product as including uh
products are sold over the internet in
terms of how that's actually going to be
policed uh as with all the other um
enforcement uh elements of the bill that
is something that uh will be done
through rul making in uh in
DHS uh so um you whether whether it's a
u and in terms of uh whether the origin
of the product is uh from New Hampshire
or from out of state uh it does for with
with the exception of food products it
doesn't matter where the uh product is
coming from it needs to be registered uh
with food products there is currently a
limitation on being able to trans uh to
sell a food product with CBD in it uh
made in New Hampshire out of state and
that's be if doing that would violate a
Federal
Regulation and uh that's why we have uh
said that food products need to be uh
just within the state and there's also a
um Clause there that says that if the
federal government uh gets rid of the
Restriction then uh there is no then New
Hampshire will have no restriction
either uh so I I think that uh covers
the um the internet sales part um and in
there's another part that um so uh
chairman Pearl and I uh did the did the
final Amendment and what we did was in
the the the amendment that you saw
yesterday had an appropriation which uh
would have come from otherwise unused
funds uh in the governor's discretion we
remove that appropriation and the entire
funding will come through the canabal
program fund which uh will be donated to
by people in the dist
R thank you representative I think
that's a key important part to this
amendment is that this program will be
self-funding or it will not exist we're
not looking for any general fund
Appropriations and I I think the the
industry is asking for this program and
the industry is willing to support it
and I I think that is a something that I
can
support there any other discussion
representative uh Pearl thank you for
that and I just want to underscore that
that this is really coming from the
industry uh it's it's Market driven
they've seen you know exponential growth
in the industry and at the same time
they've seen a number of Bad actors
enter and they feel that if we can't
tighten this up in terms of the labeling
and ensure that the consumer is getting
the product that they purchase uh that
it could uh in the long term hurt the
industry thank you representative kapan
yeah I don't know I mean maybe this is
something you've already considered Mr
chair thanks for taking my question but
I'm just curious about the provision
that says that all food products with
CBD have to be uh how's it worded that
the CBD has to be uh from New Hampshire
so I my my question and my curiosity is
how much of of the of hemp is actually
being grown in New Hampshire at this
point to make that possible so I'll
take can correct me if I
the uh
so so the the food product as so let
let's say we're talking about uh a
brownie or um well just say we're
talking about a brownie um that food Pro
the food product is baked in New
Hampshire and the uh and the CBD is
added to it in New Hampshire but the
origin of the CBD that is added to it
doesn't need to be New Hampshire the it
just needs to be uh a uh a CBD product
that has been approved that that has
gone through the registration product
project process in New Hampshire so uh
let's say that the the CBD manufacturer
is in Colorado they you know a New
Hampshire Bakery buys that buys their
CBD from Colorado they make sure that it
is um from a approved uh a New Hampshire
approved source and then they add it to
the brownie in New Hampshire and that
brownie can only be sold in New
Hampshire does that
clarify thank you yeah that clarifies
thank you all right any any further
discussion points questions
concerns all right not seeing
any so we have a motion on the table to
uh move amendment number two 0
21-45 which is an amendment to House
Bill
272 I'm going to and the U Move the
amendment as a to pass excuse me and I'm
going to uh ask the clerk to call the
role CH represent Aaron yes represent
yes represent
bille
yes represent Davis yes represent
Stapleton yes
Yesa yes Kennedy yes Mason yes
s yes repr Bixby
yesus yes bden yes Duty yes Murray yes
Von kinsky yes
Kap would you state that
again sorry yeah yes thank you represent
Highland yes Perez yes Mr chair yes
motion passes 19
Z okay so I'm looking to representative
dsy for a motion of
otpa uh yes I would like to move House
Bill 20 uh 272
uh as uh otpa ought to pass with
Amendment all right do I have a second
second representative Stapleton as a
second representative dsy you recognize
to speak to any further comments you
have to the bill as amended no I think
we've pretty much covered it okay thank
you any other discussion amongst the
members of the
committee all right seeing none I'm
going to ask the clerk to call the role
which is uh House Bill 272 otpa with
amendment number 202-
045h represent yes repres yes represent
Vero
yes represent Davis yes Stapleton yes
hola yes Kennedy yes Mason yes sour yes
Bixby yes
yesus yes Balden yes Duty yes Murray yes
kinsky yes
mlan yes Highland yes perz yes Mr chair
yes motion passes
190 now that we have no appropriation in
this bill I believe we can put this on
the consent calendar
is there any
objection I will check with the
speaker's office to be certain but if
there if it can go on I will put it
on thank you
committee thank you
okay when the clerk is ready next we
will EXA House Bill 177
okay next up we have House Bill
177 prohibiting the sighting of a
landfill near a state park I am going to
look to uh representative verville for a
motion thank you Mr chairman uh I move
House Bill one 1 77
itl do I have a
second I'll second it
yes thank you representative
sbor okay we have a
uh yes we have a motion of itl moved and
seconded I will recognize representative
verville to speak to his
motion thank you Mr chairman uh the
reason I mve this bill to be itl is that
while it is a well-intentioned
bill um it's a bit misleading I think in
in its its aim and its aim uh seems to
be directed at a particular uh project
in the in the North country located to
Forest Lake uh State Park and when we
heard the testimony uh we heard a lot of
testimony about protecting surface
waters as well as state parks and
there's nothing in the bill uh that
protects uh surface waters or or
groundwater we heard testimony on
groundwater it does nothing to change
the the regulations it simply um forbids
the sighting of a landfill within two
miles of a state park a fairly
convenient distance given um the
proposed sighting given Forest Lake
State Parks um position geographical
position I was invited to visit uh
Forest Lake uh residents and I I took
them up on that opportunity I visited
the state park this project is not
visible uh from the developed part of
the state park in that area um so while
I am sympathetic to the sponsors of the
of the bill I don't believe that this is
an appropriate vehicle for accomplishing
the desired goal um and so um that is
why I'm making a motion of it
thank you representative I expect
there'll be a lot of discussion on this
bill so I will ask everyone to just put
their hand up and I will go through in
the order that I see them uh
representative saus I'll recognize you
first
unmute there you go what this bill
attempts to do is take a very precious
resource for the State of New Hampshire
and that is our uh state parks and put a
buffer around them and um we have
received testimony from a man named
Stephen Walker in the form of a letter
and he went through all of the state
parks in New Hampshire that don't have
zoning and also um
he made a list he intersected the list
to see which ones could possibly have um
a state a a landfill put next to them
and those state parks would be Lake
Francis State Park Coleman State Park
andr Goen Wayside State Park umbagog
State park MW walk State Park Forest
Lake State Park Wellington State Park
White Lake State Park and ditch fille
Knox ditch fille Knox State Park we our
one of our best resources here and um is
that we are a tourist
destination um
especially in the in the fall and the
winter when um we have the leaf peeping
season and right now they're having a
boom year up there with all the skiing
it's um
um it's just so fabulous up there and to
just there's so many other places in New
Hampshire to put a state park it does
not have to be there and we've heard
today
already that we don't even have a plan
the uh Solid Waste plan is so many years
out of
date and so just to um keep building
them without a forward Bing plan it
seems ludicrous to me and um I just
that's where my feelings are with
it it's it this to protect our natural
resources is first second of all water
is life third the tourist industry the
mom and pop Industries up there need to
have
protection that's all Mr chairman thank
you representative
[Music]
Balden thank you Mr
chairman uh I am extremely opposed to an
itl motion and and obviously I'm going
to vote against it uh and and that's for
a number of reasons first is that
tourism is a major economic driver for
New Hampshire especially in the North
Country I have here petitions from 40
small business owners in the neighboring
town of Littleton who opposed the
proposed landfill near Forest Lake I'd
like to think that they know better than
anyone about the economic implications
of a project for their local area even
Governor suu's Commissioner of business
and economic Affairs Taylor Caswell has
come out against this landfill on nhpr's
the exchange just a couple days before
the public
hearing it's clear to me that our state
parks are the secret sauce of our
tourism industry they're just as much a
part of the New Hampshire Advantage as
no sales tax or income tax is
secondly well we've certainly talked a
lot about one particular proposed
landfill this bill is not exclusive to
Forest Lake I want to remind everyone
that this bill is about all of our state
parks think about Rolland State Park in
your neck of the woods representative
Kennedy or Silver Lake uh in your
District representative
hola these places have been sacred to
the residents and visitors of our state
going back
Generations my dad took me to Puckaway
when I was a kid he also took me to
Kingston State Park and White Lake in
Tamworth now I take my daughter to those
places and you know what's changed in 30
years since my dad took me to those
Parks absolutely
nothing and that's the beauty of our
Parks as the prime sponsor mentioned
it's like going back in
time if we place a landfill next to your
favorite state park what do you think
it'll look like in 30
years think it'll smell
like additionally it's a well-known fact
that the EPA has stated that all
landfills leak
eventually so if we don't pass this bill
and a landfill is placed close to a
state park it's not a question of if the
park will be negatively affected by the
landfill it's a question of
when in the past couple years we've been
learning a lot about the dangers of
pasas look at the K landfill on the Sea
Coast it's been leaking toxic chemicals
into the water for decades and we've
seen a um a pediatric cancer cluster
emerge there if you've ever been a
Disneyland in Anaheim California you'll
notice that when you go through the gate
there's a sign that reads and this is
real Disneyland contains chemicals known
to the state of California to cause
cancer birth defects and other
reproductive harm do we want to have to
put a sign like that up at pakway or
White
Lake a two-mile buffer zone around an
important natural resource like a state
park is not without precedent in the
United States I've sent a letter around
to the committee members from the head
of the Raleigh North Carolina office of
the fish and wildlife service which is
part of the Department of the Interior
this letter was sent to the North
Carolina House and Senate environment
and agriculture committees when they
were considering similar
legislation it laid out technical
information to justify a fem buffer zone
around National Wildlife refuges the
bill that was ultimately passed and
signed in the law did include that
fivemile buffer and also included a on
Mile buffer around gameland and a two
mile buffer around state
parks so North Carolina does exactly
what we're proposing
here furthermore Georgia has a 3.2 mile
buffer zone around their historic sites
and New Jersey has a six and a quar mile
buffer zone around their National Parks
and Wildlife
areas and these are not States known for
their overreaching Environmental
Protections the letter went into detail
about why these buffers are established
they're established because of a
landfill is placed near a precious
natural resource any one of the
following negative impacts can occur
diminished public enjoyment and
resulting reduction in visitation due to
viewscape noise and odor
impacts various negative impacts to
Native Wildlife from landfill scavengers
through displacement depredation of
nesting sites and
harassment modification of hydrology
patterns and potential off-site
consequences water quality degradation
resulting from potential failures and
unintended
releases alteration of function and
value of local Wetland areas and
increased vehicular traffic particularly
large trucks and associated impacts to
Wildlife I am not anti-
landfill I understand trash has to go
somewhere but I do think we should make
sure that they're placed in such a way
to reduce the negative
consequences but placing one just feet
from a state park is not how we reduce
negative consequences it's how we
guarantee
them so to sum it up the message should
be loud and clear here small businesses
don't want to see landfills near State
Parks
citizens of our state don't want that
and visitors of our state don't want
them either this is a common sense and
bipartisan bill that protects all of our
state parks from the severe negative
consequences of nearby
landfills and I hope you join me in
voting no on this itl motion thank you
Mr chair thank you representative thank
you representative representative holas
I'll allow you to go next since you were
invoked in representative V statement um
one of I know this is a very difficult
decision and this has been a very
difficult decision for everybody on the
committee we take what people say very
seriously we've heard a lot of testimony
for people in opposition and we've also
received testimony or received letters
from people who want this project to go
forward uh not this bill but I'm sorry
who want this bill not to go forward
people of Dalton one of the things that
that I kind of take note with is that um
you know we the part of this bill that
that I can't get over is the fact that
it's not that there's a two mile buffer
being proposed around a state park I
think that sounds like a you know I
think that sounds reasonable in many
terms what really bothers me is it
didn't occur to anyone to make this bill
before this project in Dalton was being
executed and and that to me seems like
we're we're using legislative powers to
um overreach into an area and and that's
what I'm I'm really against and and I
understand as you had mentioned
representative Bolton about you know
invoking Silver Lake I I totally
understand what you're saying I will say
though that we can't hold some of these
some of these places up on a pedestal
because one of the word on the street
and H is the best time to go to Silver
Lake is when it's frozen because there's
a lot of housing around there and quite
frankly they get a lot of um bacterial
problems so I although I I'm not using
that as a reason I'm just saying I'm not
let's put everything up on a pedestal
because not everything is without
problems sometimes already thank you
very much thank you representative uh
representative
Perez um thank you for giving me the
opportunity um I will I will say that I
I I will support
177 I've visited a lot of parks I've
been going around
and then seeing exactly you know the
beautiful areas in New
Hampshire we have so many people coming
out of stay because New Hampshire is so
beautiful I have the opportunity last
weekend to go and visit this park and
exactly and then I and I saw exactly
what this this this project is going to
be and then I saw the houses and and
people going to be able to see the trash
I consider some of the small businesses
in the area and then how horrible is
going to be having these TR the trucks
with trash
driving by these little as small stores
in in the area uh the economy is going
to be
affected uh the and we're not talking
about just this park we have so many
beautiful areas and not stake we have so
many people coming like even from around
the world just to visit New Hampshire
because we have such a beautiful state
that I'm so proud I always told people
that come in and visit new hire because
in new hire we have so many beautiful
places to visit but we don't want to put
this
trash places close to the beautiful
parks and then not only that but let
companies bring trash at a state we just
heard from another bill that
Massachusetts is bringing some of their
trash to our state because it's cheaper
to bring it to New Hampshire why are we
going to
allow a company and then someone to put
more trash into our into our state we
has to protect our parks and that's all
I has to
say thank you thank you representative
uh representative
Duty yes thank you uh I just wanted to
make a couple of points f first of all
um even though cassella locating or
trying to locate uh in this area was the
impetus uh for this bill it's not the
focus of the bill I know they want us to
believe that it is but it really isn't
it's the state parks that are the focus
of this regarding the
um um the comment that if we were really
concerned about state parks we would
have legislated this years ago there are
thousands and thousands and thousands of
problems that have never come before the
legislature because our constituents
haven't brought us to them and we don't
know they're a problem here we have a
situation where our constituents brought
us this issue we looked at the broader
issue of not only Lake uh Lake Forest
but the fact that this could happen at
at any of our state parks and looking at
our state you know Statewide we decided
that it was important to have
legislation going forward in this area
uh regarding this being a vendetta
against one company I would say this is
nothing different than years ago when
certain cars started gas tanks exploded
when they uh were in an accident that
wasn't a vend
against Chevy or or GM or Ford okay it
was an indication that we had a problem
in the industry and the industry was
looked at and they were asked to make
changes so something like this didn't
happen again so I would ask you to look
at it in the spirit that this
legislation was um was put forward thank
you
thank you representative I think I'm
going to jump in here myself for just a
minute and uh there just a couple of
points first off I want to thank the
committee uh you're all bringing great
points we're all having a very civilized
and and excellent discussion and I I
hope that the rest of the Committees
that are dealing with bills whether
maybe the committee isn't in agreement
are all watching this and and learning
and understanding that you can have a
conversation amongst a group of people
that don't always agree and it can be
civil and polite and respectful so I
want to applaud all of you for that
first off I guess the points I want to
make here is my main concern with this
bill and it was the same concern I had
last year and I didn't get my questions
answered this year either this is a
landowner rights issue I have some a
real problem with putting an arbitrary
limit in statute that isn't backed by
science and and I certainly appreciate
the uh all of the work that
representative Balton has done on this
because he's raised some great points
and brought some great information
we had a long discussion about this in
our caucus as well I as I know you did
on on the Democratic caucus as well and
and I'm positive that that happened and
we have a lot of concern about the the
similar problems that are being raised
by this bill we just don't feel like
this is the right vehicle to get us
there I I've myself personally and and
representative ER and my vice chair have
had lengthy conversations with Dees
about this had some real discussion
about is there way we could perhaps
amend this and and change it and get to
a point where we could achieve what
we're trying to do which is help the
community impact perhaps be a part of uh
the sighting process we haven't got
there yet we're trying to find a way to
do that uh this bill doesn't get there
in my opinion uh again I'm concerned
about the rabbit hole we'd be going down
by saying okay well we don't want we're
going to put this
arbitrary um buffer zone on well well
what's next a dairy farm we don't like
the way that smells we don't like the
way that looks so we could you know we
could put that and say that couldn't be
there and I realize they're not exactly
the same but my point is when we start
down this path we go in a direction that
I think is dangerous for a legislature
to go into um I I respect completely
everyone's opinion on this because I
know it's all coming from a a place of
where we all care about our state and I
I want to make sure that we all know
that in the end that none of us are
still certainly advocating for
destruction of our state parks but we
have to find uh some common ground in in
a manner that would allow us to put the
regulations that we feel we need are in
place but but not stepping on that the
landowner rights for one and uh that
that's a major one for me and I I will
reflect back on the previous bill that
we just heard we had uh a lot of
testimony coming from many people about
ways that we can solve our Solid Waste
issues I think we're going in a great
Direction there you know the key
certainly is reduction and we all accept
we have to have a place to go with the
remaining parts uh but one of the things
that really stood out to me in that
testimony was Dees does a great job at
what they do that stood out to me and I
have confidence in Dees that they're
doing a great job in what they do and I
have confidence that they're paying
attention in when they're citing
landfills so for that reason I'm going
to support the itl and I appreciate all
of you listening to my my two senseful
this with that I going to go to
representative Kaplan is
next thank you Mr chair and I appreciate
your your uh your your analysis I think
you have some good points um to me it it
really comes down and and I recognize
that this is a difficult issue with lots
of valid viewpoints on both sides but to
me I I just look at it as a cost benefit
analysis and I just say you know what is
the cost of this bill going forward
um and I see the the sunk time in
investment of of the private company who
uh has spent year you know I don't know
how many years in in the planning
process for this project but then I
think well you know if there any if
there are like any business worth worth
its salt they've already started
planning for this eventuality and I
don't think it's really going to affect
their bottom line much um there might be
a cost of the landowner but really the
cost of the land owner is nil because he
still owns a land and he can sell it to
another user um what is the benefit the
benefit it allows the state to implement
a thoughtful
analysis of uh sighting possibilities
and using uh a meth methodical and
science-based Analysis to find a proper
site to take care of our of our common
problem which is what do we do with our
Solid Waste um so that's that's how I
look at
it represent representative
yes thank you Mr chairman you know I
just because we're having a conversation
I just want to Circle back to a couple
of thing so I do a lot of camping with
my family and we camp almost exclusively
at New Hampshire state parks and we've
done that for decades right I bring my
children there
too and Puck away how many times did
they close the beach at Puckaway last
summer because of feal matter in the
water
which is actually caused by the
campground by the state
park how many people are aware that
umbagog State Park got started right by
the purchasing of a private Campground
that was a private Campground that the
state purchased and converted into a
state park so would we have offered a
bill to protect the private owner of
that property had a landfill been
proposed within a 2 mile radius it's a
fair question Lake Francis State Park
one of my favorites I go up north every
year for Independence Day for a week
with my family and we stay at Lake
Francis I've got reservation coming up
uh this
year Lake Francis State Park was a
private Campground that the state
purchased and converted into a state
park so if a landfill would have been
proposed within two miles of that
property when it was privately held and
that was not that long ago would we be
considering legislation to protect it
when we talk about the small businesses
that we that potentially could be
negatively impacted by a
landfill up by Forest Lake not on Forest
Lake near Forest Lake would we support a
bill that would prohibit the sighting of
a landfill within two miles of any
private small business that may
anticipate a negative impact to their
business would we file that bill would
we support that
bill the state parks sort of are the
buffer right when there's the very
valuable piece of property the the the
monument the natural wonder that we want
to preserve it is the state park it's
that land that provides the buffer
around that particular item and so to
extend it out past that um for me is is
a bit of a stretch too far and
representative sopus hits the nail on
the head absolutely right this is a
zoning issue this is a zoning issue so
Dalton doesn't have zoning that
precludes the landfill or at least uh
Narrows the possibility of its sighting
the state parks that we just heard about
or state parks that are are in or near
communities that have
chosen chosen not to adopt zoning all
right so that's how they have chosen to
operate their communities those are the
decisions that they've made that's how
they want to govern themselves and so
when a neighboring Community then says
well they don't have zoning and now this
is going in and I don't I don't like it
to come with basically de facto state
level
zoning doesn't seem like the doesn't
seem like the best approach to solve
that problem so um so if a community AB
buts another community and and that
Community doesn't like the zoning
policies of the neighboring Community
can they come to the state legislature
to to get an RSA that that puts their de
facto um zoning into place for other
communities I mean I don't think so that
those are the analogies of of what we're
talking about when we listen to these
these points being
articulated I live in Deerfield okay I
am I am almost AB budding be Brook State
Park puer Way state park has property
you know into into Deerfield so do a
bear Brook um so so I get I get the
value of the state park but to say that
we're going to have a TW mile buffer
around every state park for a landfill
only right what about what about
mining what about
excavation what about um the development
of of particularly tall structures for
whatever
reason one of the complaints that we
heard you know is noise and runoff at
Forest Lake that they feel that that's
going to threaten the state park there's
already noise up there when I visited
all you could hear was the den of
snowmobiles the property in question is
currently being managed for um aggregate
production right sand and gravel and
it's also being managed for forestry I I
drove up as far as I could on the on the
property's uh Access Road till I hit the
gate and it is quite clear that that
property is already being managed for
things that bring heavy equipment large
trucks in and out perhaps there'll be
more trucks with the landfill maybe not
I I don't know um so I I think we need
to to keep a lot of these things in mind
and and so again it's for all of these
reasons combined uh that for me this is
I itl and and that's why I'm going to
support uh the itl motion thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative uh
representative Aaron you haven't had a
chance to speak
yet thank you very much and I gotta Echo
what um chairman Pearl had said about
everybody body on this committee having
such very valid points and working
together and talking and and I I can't
say more about how much I appreciate
that since I have sat on other
committees and it's not like this
um that being said I I agree um with the
points that representative vervo came up
with the the points that representative
Balden has come up with all of these
points really really they they they
ReSound with you know it resonates with
me um but what I see with this bill is
that it's more or
less citing
criteria
and this sighting criteria is made
without really any technical proof or
technical sense I mean why not three
miles five miles 10 miles I mean there's
no it just seems too arbitrary for me
and and as well as you know yes let's
protect our state parks but what about
our national parks our historical sites
our tourist areas our recreational rail
Trails those are also places where
tourists go to where we cherish for our
recre for our very limited recreational
time these days so I I'm I'm very torn
with it but you know I think we also
have to go back to the statute
statute that we already have that Dees
has to
follow and maybe we need to do more to
make sure that they do follow it that
says that uh with regard to public
benefit requirements for Solid Waste
Management that facilities necessary to
meet Solid Waste capacity needs must be
designed and operated in a manner which
will protect the public health and the
state's natural environment we've been
all talking about the same thing it's
here in the
statute um we want to meet the capacity
needs of the state while minimizing
adverse environmental public health and
long-term economic impacts it's here in
the statutes the department shall also
consider as part of its public benefit
determination the concerns of the
citizens and the governing bodies of the
host municipality County and district
and other affected persons it's in the
statute
so Dees has to take into consideration
all of these factors and I hope that
they will um and that being said I think
that the working group that we discussed
prior to this bill will go a long way
also to bring about change into how we
look at site um consider are the are the
landfills and you know we do need the
landfill um
so I I I have to agree that um this bill
does not really do what we want it to do
and so I I have to go with itl thank
[Music]
you thank you representative uh
representative saakes you have your hand
up is that still up or did you have
further comments yes sir Mr chairman I
wanted to just say that
um this bill has already come before
this committee once before and um it was
Bill
1319 and it was last session so for the
argument that um this bill was late to
the game um that is incorrect and so um
I just wanted to have that on the
record thank you representative uh
representative Murray you haven't had a
chance to speak yet go ahead thank you
um yeah you know part of the
conversation that we're having around
um what is best moving forward in citing
for all um natural resources around land
um state parks um I think is an
important consideration about how we
proactively move forward additionally I
have heard concerns directly from
constituents who own property in that
area who site concerns around property
values of their own properties and I I
think that that is an important also
part to consider when we talk about
natural resources and we're also talking
about the use of the state parks in the
environment so I think this is a broader
issue in my than just for this one
Community I think this is we would be
potentially setting precedent for years
to
come thank you uh representative Duty uh
yes thank you Mr chairman I just want to
comment on uh some of the statements
made about arbitrariness you know
regarding the two miles uh I think in
statute we have a number of um
situations that mimic this exactly I
don't know all of them but I know
regarding Wetlands uh we in I believe
the state law uh is a wetland boundary
is uh 100 feet and I think the the
cities and the towns can change it I
know in Nashville we have a critical um
we have a prime wet lens of 75 feet and
a critical wet lens of 40 feet arbitrary
I mean there's no science based on
exactly why that should be so I think we
already have it in State Statute that um
you know there are areas that are marked
out and it's an arbitrary er um an
arbitrary number just because you know
it it seemed to be right at the time um
so I'm I'm really not concerned about
that I mean you have to pick out a
number and and people talk about it and
they think about it it's it's just like
HB 272 why did we choose
$250 for a registration fee well you
know we talked this person that person
you know Dilly dallad around about it
and said that seemed to be reasonable
and I'm sure that's we have that in
statute over and over and over again so
I don't think we're cutting any new
ground if we go ahead and pass this bill
with a two- mile
liit representative representative B uh
thank you Mr chair I'm I'm a little
surprised at some of the stuff I'm I'm
hearing um I I've heard comments that
are state parks they aren't that
great what message does that send to
visitors Silver
Lake Puck away they have they have
issues sometime we have to shut them
down because of bacteria let's just
build a mountain of trash next to what
message does that send and what kind of
solution is that that doesn't make sense
to me it doesn't make
sense
well representative I'm not sure where
you heard that comment because I did not
hear that comment that anyone disparaged
their state parks I I think the comment
was more related to something that
representative H discussed about that
not all things are are as pristine as
we're always saying there I think that
was more of a comment but I I appreciate
and understand what you're saying
is there any further com representative
Dy did you have another comment well I
just want to make one comment and that's
to reiterate what other people have said
uh it is very enjoyable to be able to
engage in a policy discussion where we
have differences of opinion you know but
we're all trying to do the best for the
state and I think there are very few
committees uh in which we can do this
and I want you to know that how much I
ALS so appreciate this thank you
representative uh representative
Perez yeah I want to Echo that to be
honest of me coming from the minority
group and then this is the first time
that I'm I'm a state representative I
feel so welcoming in this committee and
I feel like I
can I can use my voice and I can be he
and like with all the respect we all
respect each other and then um
when it comes to this bill to be honest
we have an amazing State we have an
amazing parks and I'm I'm only not
seeing just for this generation but with
it you know for the next Generations and
I have so many so many friends and so
many family members that come from all
around the world and then I I have that
privilege to tell them you know that we
have such a beautiful stay
and I would love to protect the parks
and you know
I I don't want then to bring trash from
out State we have enough problem with
our trash why are we going to allow more
trash to come into our state we already
have issues with water being
contaminated the air is
contaminated
um I you know I I see this as something
that we can like work as a committee and
with all my respect I will ask you to
support this bill because we need to we
we need to protect and this is not a
this is not about one project this is
about you know everything that so
beautiful in our state thank you
representative uh representative
staple well thank you Mr chair
um I I'm going to go with supporting the
itl but
sympathetic to the bills intent and the
plights of the land
owners and I really appreciate um
representative wen's testimony earlier
on with interesting information about
buffers at different
states um the only question I would have
to satisfy myself would be uh what the
details of those laws are if there was
any other measuring criteria other than
raw number
buffer and that's my problem with uh
this bill it's we're closing the Barn
Door after the horse is rushing out or
maybe while it's rushing
out another expression devil in the
details or lack
thereof um I would think that a bill
would be better suited to advisory
criteria to
Dees and ask some of
zoning not only um with the groundwater
issue but you know line of sight
Aesthetics uh green barriers like that
have been utilized in other areas and
other
states that preserve atics and sight
deter wind transmission of
odors dampen sound from machine
operations of recycling
centers um as well as the groundwater
considerations and uh probably some many
other things that could go into
measuring
criteria um the raw number doesn't do it
for
me um it should be two miles maybe it
should be one mile maybe it should be
three or six miles but that's dependent
upon Case by case where the site is in
the
circumstances and so I think the bill
fall short as as much as I sympathize
with its intent and and grieve for the
the land owners and the neighbors who
feel grieved about having a d sighted in
their
neighborhood um I would I would
encourage a better bill with more uh
detail and uh advisory criteria to the
dees and so I'm going to support the
itm thank you pres well folks we've had
about an hour of discussion on this um
we're not really hearing any new points
uh I'll continue on as long as you want
to I'll just remind you that we do have
a few more bills we need to exact so um
representative Kaplan you have your hand
up yeah I just want to add one more uh
point of view and that's uh the fact
that if we go ahead with iing this bill
that would be in the face of uh what's
pretty amazing amount of public support
for this bill especially from people in
the in the local area and I think that
it would it would be seen as kind of uh
um arrogant of us to just discount that
and and itl this bill given some kind of
vague notion that it's not specific
enough or not detailed enough
scientifically especially given what we
know about the lack of uh the lack of
capacity in in the dees for doing that
kind of strategic analysis and the fact
that you know this would be a good time
to pause and and and and allow us to
catch up to where we are in terms of
dealing with the solid waste problem
before we rush ahead with a project that
is very very you
unpopular so that's that's all I'm
saying thank you representative
representative Kor thank you Mr chair um
I appreciate and respect everyone's
testimony here today and what they're
saying and your
opinions the one thing that I fall back
on is yes we've had issues in the state
represent B mention
cly had those issues but I think that
Dees in moving forward and with new
technologies has managed those issues
and is very
cognizant that these happened in the
past and will be doubly sure that they
won't happen again I mean there already
change there's things that didn't happen
previous landfills that are happening in
this one just by the design of it I
think that we have a Department of
Environmental Services and we have a
commissioner who is very aware of our
natural resources that we are a tourist
State and again this is a zoning issue
and I think we have to look to them in
their guidance and their
expertise they are not going to
jeopardize our natural resources it's
stated right the RSA they cannot and I
think that moving you
know nobody wants to have a landfill in
their backyard I mean I'm just going to
say it
but
EnV is determined that this is a
suitable
site it just happens to
be in in the town of Dalton where in
near State Park if this was somewhere
else would we be having the same
discussion I would venture to say yes so
thank you Mr chair I think I'd like a
point of clarification there
representative PTO I I don't believe
that the uh the dees has made that
determination yet that it's suitable I
believe they're still accepting the
application oh well Mr chair thank you
for that but I may I just say something
that if they do accept the
application then they then I believe
they would have done their due diligence
sure I apologize for I think just about
all all of us has had a chance to speak
except representative Bixby and now he's
he's got his hand back up again so I if
you're all okay with it I think I'm
going to let representative viby speak
and then we'll put this to a vote
because we've been quite a while here
yeah I um I'm going to be voting against
the itl because um I feel strongly that
we should be defending our state parks
uh and that the um the state parks are
really one of the major drivers of our
touristry industry and there are a lot
of small businesses that depend on those
state parks to uh you to provide their
customer base and uh the sighting of a
landfill right next to a state park
would be a uh would diminish the value
of that Park we do have a lot of other
land in the state that is not within two
miles of a state park and uh that is you
know available you know with the same
due diligence that Dees will give for
any sighting uh uh issue uh that is
available for development as a landfill
or other businesses as as long as they
meet the sighting um the permitting
requirement so I think that making that
two mile around a state park cutout is
an appropriate way of defending our
state parks thank
you thank you representative I just have
a procedural question just so I
understand if I could go ahead
representative B um well I I just one of
the things I want to mention was that I
I appreciate representative Kaplan
mentioned that that the blue sheet was
335 to 33 but the uh the procedural
question I had was that um I have an
amendment put together for this bill and
it's been a while since we've had
something like this and I just want to
make sure I I understand would we have
to defeat the it
motion before we could talk about about
any Amendment to the bill is that
correct that is correct thank you very I
wasn't sure myself so I checked with the
clerk today because I wanted to make
sure procedurally I handled this well so
that I was giving your Amendment uh the
due process that it deserves but he
informed me if we have an itl on the
table then we have to you would have to
defeat that because you can't amend an
itl motion great thanks you so much
you're very
welcome all right is uh everybody all
set to put this to a
vote all right if so I'm going to ask
the clerk to call the rooll we have an
itl motion on the table and seconded on
House Bill 177 and I'll ask the clerk to
uh call a roll thank you represent Aon
yes repres K yes represent
verbo yes represent Davis yes represent
Stapleton yes represent mola yes
represent Kennedy yes represent Mason
yes s yes represent vixy
no sopus no Balden no Duty no muray no
kinsky no pres
kin no represents Highland no pres no Mr
chair
yes motion passes 10 to n
again I thank everyone in the committee
for a very spirited and respectful
debate and I I look forward to uh
working on the next
[Laughter]
bill okay House Bill 199 is the one
we'll do
next now when the clerk is
ready yes
[Applause]
okay I um are you ready or yeah uh go
ahead uh so um we'll be executing House
Bill 199 and I will look to
representative Bixby for an
amendment okay so I um move House Bill
199 and offer amend Amendment 2021
d351 H do we have a second seconds
seconded by representative F and I will
recognize rep representative Bixby to
speak to his
board okay and I just have a couple of
notes Here I want to bring up um okay so
um so I'm speaking to the amendment
specifically uh what um I worked on the
amendment with representative Homa and
uh and she was very helpful in terms of
uh helping iron out some uh some of the
weaker points and helping me make them
much stronger so uh the uh one thing
that uh has been changed throughout is
the uh origin the bists um as introduced
had the phrase uh climate change and
environmental change and that's changed
throughout as uh changing environment
and climate or claiming changing climate
and environment or changes in climate
and environment depending on the wording
context
uh the uh there was a some question
about how the word mitigation was being
used and I decided that um based on
testimony from uh Roger Nunan uh who
helped me draft the the original Bill uh
it actually didn't make sense in the
context of New Hampshire to have the
term mitigation and it actually just
create created more confusion so the
term mitigation has been removed uh I uh
changed the def the definition of
adaptation to remove the phrase climate
change and environmental change so it's
a cleaner definition of the word
adaptation and uh at representative
homa's suggestion I have uh included uh
more emphasis on drought resilience so
uh that's that's what um what the
amendment does
thank you
representative is there any further
discussion or
comment representative hola thank you
chair I just want to say thank you to
representative Bixby for letting me work
with him on this and I I was really
pleased with the end product and I was
really pleased with bringing drought
more in the Forefront of that and I I
just want to say thank you for being
open to these changes and and taking the
time to talk with me on
that you're most welcome any further
discussion from the
committee
yes all right seeing none I am going to
and I am sorry I can't find my copy of
the amendment right this
second going to ask uh the clerk to call
the roll on ought to pass on amendment
number 202-351-1010
yes repres K yes represent
B yes represent Davis yes steton yes
representative mola yes representative
Kennedy yes repres Mason yes sour yes
Bixby
yesus yes
repr Bolin yes represent Duty yes Murray
yes vinsky yes
Kaplan yes Highland yes
Perez yes representative Perez I need to
ask you to turn your camera on I'm sorry
I didn't realize I have it at off
yes yes
[Music]
motion passes 19 to
Z without uh any objection I'll put this
on the consent calend ad I'm sorry yeah
how about the amendment hey you want to
adopt the actual bill sorry I'm getting
tired all right uh so we have passed the
amendment and uh I'm looking now for a
motion of
otpa to representative
Bixby okay so I move uh otpa with
Amendment 2021
d351
H um did I get the bill number hp9 199
um 2021
H so
moved repres seconds would you like any
further uh discussion on the
representive VI yeah I just want to um
emphasize that this is this will uh uh
provide a a scientific update to the
state soil state soil statute that will
allow our uh conservation districts to
uh be more competitive for Grants the
grants they're using to do the really
good work they're already
doing representative any further
discussion from the
committee representative Stapleton thank
you Mr chair I just want to quickly
state that uh this was some nice
collaborative work and earlier on I
wasn't comfortable with the language in
the original bill but the language that
was adopted through hard work um very
comfortable and appropriate nice job
thank
you thank you
representa any further
discussion all right seeing none I'm
going to ask the uh clerk to call the
role on house B 199 otpa with Amendment
202-
0351 representative Erin yes
representative k no representative
Vero yes represent Davis yes represent
Stapleton
Yesa yes represent Kennedy yes Mason yes
s yes Biby
yesus
yes yes repres Duty yes Murray yes
vinsky yes K yes
Highland yes represent
Perez yes Mr chair yes motion passes 18
to1 any objection to putting this on the
consent
calendar all right then I shall do
that when the clerk is ready we will do
House Bill 367 next Mr chair oh I'm
sorry question um on um question for the
chair um on on 177 can we get a Minority
Report on that or yes absolutely
okay I was going to discuss the report
deadlines but while she's getting ready
I'll do that for
well I'm
still so any any minority reports or uh
the folks who doing the majority reports
I'm going to need to have you get those
Into Me
Tomorrow by I think by noon is okay but
the earlier the better so that I have a
chance to approve them and get back to
you if there's any concerns sure so the
earlier the better I have to get them in
place by tomorrow I believe it's 4M is
my deadline okay and I'm just follow um
can I'm curious can Minority Report
include an amendment or can it not
because we never discuss the
amendment that I don't know the answer
to but I will inquire okay I can I can
answer I can provide an answer to that
so uh The Minority Report report
requires that you say the motion that
you would have wanted so you can say so
you would say that the motion that you
that you would have wanted was the otpa
and the the amendment number that you
would have wanted okay then that
amendment number that amendment can get
the calendar correct and and the so the
the amendment number doesn't doesn't
actually appear in the calendar but uh
nor does the nor does the unless you
include it in your text no nor does the
the the otpa but you but in your
Minority Report you could have said you
could say the the more minority felt
that we needed that that this should
have been uh passed with an amendment to
do such and such gotta okay I'll double
check this for the heck of it with Paul
and make sure we're on on the amendment
part too because I didn't ask him that
part I just asked him the first great
question thank
you okay next we will do uh House
Bill 367
yes and I'm looking to our
representative Mason for a motion thank
you Mr chair i' I'd like to recommend
that house bill 367 retain in committee
so we can do some additional work to it
thank you representative do we have a
second I'll second
it Sor yes s
okay so we have a motion and a second to
retain uh House Bill 387 repres
representative Mason did you want
to 367 I'm sorry making sure yes you're
right well there one under the other on
my sheet here House Bill 367 yes
representative Mason did you have any
further comments you wanted to make
thank you Mr chair some of the
information we heard today um I think we
just need to look over the language a
little bit more and and do some more
research on it and make sure that it's
what's good for everybody in the state
of New
Hampshire thank you thank you
representative any discussion from
committee members
k n I'll ask the clerk to call a rooll
on House Bill 367 with a motion of
retain represent Baron yes represent yes
represent
Vero
yes represent Davis yes represent
Stapleton yes represent M yes repres
Kennedy yes repres Mason yes
yes repr Bixby yes
represent yes represent bden yes Duty
yes uh
yes yes
K
yes yes representative
Perez yes chair yes motion pass
190 okay next uh when the clerk is ready
we will do House Bill
413 set all right I'm looking to
representative Murray for a
motion uh I'm
did you say representative uh 416 is
that correct sorry 413 yes sorry thank
you you cut out I would like to move
hb413 and offer Amendment
0343 as
otpa it's a 202-
[Music]
0343 we have a motion that is moved and
seconded a lot to
pass and we we have Amendment uh 20213
43h offered and I
will recognize representative Murray to
speak to her motion sure thank you Mr
chair as we heard much testimony and
support around addressing long-term
planning and waste disposal hierarchy
and the complex nature around our solid
waste management practices as a whole we
noted uh that we're at a critical
intersection in our ability to deal with
our refu to divert compostable waste to
promote the ability to compost including
meet and dairy and effectuate
environmental Steward
stewardship and and and with that I urge
um
otpa thank you R is there any further uh
comments or any would like to make on
the
amendment right seeing none I will ask
the clerk to call the role we have a
motion of ought to pass on amendment to
house bill 14
413 of two amendment number 202-
0343 represent Aaron
yeses yes represent
bville yes represent Davis yes represent
Stapleton yes yes represent mola yes
repr Kennedy yes Mason yes sour yes yes
vix
yesus
yesen yes Dy yes
muray yes kinsky yes
Kaplan yes
Highland yes
re
yes chair yes
passes
190 okay I will look to uh
representative Murray for an otpa motion
on House Bill
413 with Amendment
2012-03
43h yes thank you I move that
hb413 with Amendment
d343 ought to pass with amendment I have
a
second when the motion is moved and
seconded uh I'll recognize
representative Murray to speak to her
motion uh I think everything that we had
said uh in the past is applicable here
so I'd like to continue just with otpa
thank you thank you so any other
comments from the
committee well I would like to say that
I have appreciate the work that was done
on this bill from the previous uh Ena
group on on the last bill and I think
youve put together something that's
going to be really important for our
state going forward as we all know
managing our Solid Waste is of key
importance to all of
us any further
comments seeing none I'm going to ask
the clerk to call the role so we have an
amendment on the floor of ought to pass
as amended otpa on House Bill 413 with
Amendment 202-
0343 representa Aaron yes repres yes
represent
verville
yes represent Davis yes Stapleton
yes yes represent Kennedy yes represent
Mason yes
sour yes
viby yes
sopus yes bden yes Duty yes repr Murray
yes
vinsky yes sen Kaplan yes
Highland yes
Perez yes Mr chair yes motion passes
190 any objection to putting this on
consent hearing none
I Mr chair if I may I just wanted to
apologize to the committee for my my dog
jumping up on the back and and I
apologize to the members ofy
offense thank you I I didn't happen to
see him myself but I appreciate
that all right our last and final
bill House Bill
437 this is the meet inection
bill and when the clerk is ready I will
look to uh representative con to make a
motion yes I'd like to make a motion to
adopt Amendment
each I would I have a
second yes second thank you
representative I will recognize
representative comto to speak to motion
thank you Mr chair um this bill is
really necessary so that we can
understand um the issue with um the
shortage of animal slaughtering
facilities in New Hampshire and to find
out how we can make this uh State more
of
uh food security is a real issue and by
finding out why in slaugh houses why
there's a shortage and why people are
are be year in advance to get the meet
processed we will U the study committe
will be
valuable thank you representive any
further
[Music]
discussion uh yes i'
um uh I just like to uh Echo that and
and really thank representative coma for
uh broadening the scope of this bill
from uh just studing the Meat Inspection
program to studying the the underlying
issue of a lack of sufficient Slaughter
facilities and ways that we might be
able to to fix that as a
state thank you representative any
further
discussion seeing none I will ask the
clerk to call the role on an OTP on
Amendment
202- 0404
House Bill
repres repres yes represent
verville
yes represent Davis yes represent
Stapleton yes represent M yes
representative Kennedy yes represent
Mason yes Sor yes Bixby
yesus yes
repr Balden yes represent Duty yes muray
yes yes
Kaplan
yes Highland yes Perez yes Mr chair yes
motion passes
190 okay so I'll be looking to
representative coma for an to pass otpa
motion on
437 Mr chair I'd like
to Amendment
20244 do I have a second
437 I'll second that thank you
representative representative kto are
you recognized to speak to your motion I
think that I
basically all right thank you any other
comments from the
committee seeing none with the motion on
the floor is House Bill 437 otpa with
Amendment
represent Kennedy yes representative
Mason yes Sor yes Bixby
yesus yes Balden yes Duty yes pres
Murray yes binsky yes Kaplan
yes
yes Perez
yes chair yes motion passes
190 everyone okay with us going on
consent all
right once again I want to thank the
committee you've done a Long Day's Work
here we've been here since 9:00 am and I
appreciate all of your efforts this is
our final bills that we have on our
calendar so uh we won't getting together
as a committee again until we get cross
after crossover with any bills that come
over from the Senate so I'd like to
thank you all you've done a a Yen's work
here all of these bills and I know
there's been a lot of individual effort
behind the scene that it most people
don't see and I'd especially like to
thank representative Bixby because he
and I have worked uh seamlessly on many
of these bills together uh making sure
that things go smoothly on the day today
so I I give him as much credit as uh as
anyone on on making our hearing days go
smoothly so and we that our recognized
representative yes I I'd like to uh also
thank the committee for the um good
collegial work we've been doing and uh
especially thank uh chairman Pearl for
uh being a very good working partner and
uh recognizing where we can and can't
come to agreement and I'm I'm pleased
that on the whole we' managed to come to
agreement even though was there were a
few sticking points earlier we we worked
through a lot of um a lot of stuff and
I'm I'm impressed with how well our
committee is working
together representative
keus um thank you um do you know when
these bills will be on the
calendar if we get them in in time most
of all of them will make it any on
consent will definitely make it on um
next week's uh calendar as long as we
get all of our committee reports in in
time I'm not positive that uh HB uh 177
will be only because I know there's a
lot of bills already on the calendar and
I don't know for sure if it will make it
on or not but I'm certainly going to try
because I I think we've done a great job
on it and I want to get it to the floor
so we can have further our conversation
there thank you so I will say
representative Balden if you can get uh
a uh report into me as soon as you can
and you wanted an otpa amend motion for
the minority uh I think I would I would
want to discuss with with my caucus
exactly which one but perfect as as
possible you'll let me know that I
assume you're writing the blur most
likely
okay I just committed
you uh representative
Murray yeah I just wanted to say that it
was an honor to meet the new members
even though we are in a mixed sort of
hybrid and I wanted to also say thank
you to the chair for um teaching
providing learning opportunities for all
of the members to um I really enjoy
working with you guys and um it's an
honor to serve on the committee so thank
you well thank you all very much and for
those of us who are driving home safe
travels and for those of you who are
already there you got a leg up on
us all right with that I'm G to close
the hearing for today and uh we'll see
you all next week at the session don't
forget the 24th and 5ifth we have house
sessions